faire le tour de l'info qui vous
concerne toute l'actualité du Parlement
et des lois qui font votre quotidien à 8
heures la grande interview politique et
à 8h20 le club des territoires pour tout
savoir de ce qui se passe dans nos
régions avec la presse régionale l'info
vue différemment au plus près de chez
vous c'est tous les jours du lundi au
vendredi je vous attends à 7h30 sur
Public Sénat
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous très heureuse de
vous retrouver sur Public Sénat pour
suivre l'examen de la réforme des
retraites au Sénat le Sénat qui débat
maintenant depuis quatre jours sur ce
projet de loi toute la rédaction de
Public Sénat se mobilisent pour vous
faire vivre ses discussions dans
l'hémicycle où se trouve aujourd'hui
Audrey Vita qui va nous accompagner
toute la journée pour suivre et pour
analyser tout l'examen de ce texte
bonjour Audrey depuis jeudi on a
beaucoup entendu l'opposition des
groupes de gauche à travers plusieurs
notions de procédures qui ont été
défendus jeudi une motion référendaire
vendredi tout ont été rejetées et depuis
vendredi soir les sénateurs des battent
des articles et là encore on entend la
gauche la gauche qui multiplie les
prises de parole les rappels aux
règlements les amendements parfois
identiques bref toutes les armes de
l'obstruction une obstruction bien plus
calme posée courtois à ce qu'elle
assemblée mais une obstruction claire et
frontale et qui commence à agacer la
droite de l'hémicycle à la droite que
l'on entend moins qui ne veut pas faire
perdre de temps dans les débats mais qui
a permis il y a d'adopter l'un des
premiers gros morceaux de ce texte
puisqu'il hier soir le Sénat a adopté
l'article premier article qui prévoit la
suppression d'un certain nombre de
régimes spéciaux de retraite qui
existent encore comme la RATP ou encore
la Banque de France et cela pour les
nouveaux entrants et donc Audrey
aujourd'hui on devrait débattre de
l'article 2 un autre sujet majeur de ce
texte quels sont vos prévisions Audrey
oui Tam il reste encore quelques
articles additionnels autour de
l'article premier est près de 80
amendements et sous amendements en plus
des sénateurs qui ont demandé à prendre
la parole il faudra au moins trois
heures pour terminer cette partie et
puis il y a la question de la vie du
Conseil d'État ça peut paraître un peu
périphérique mais cela fait plusieurs
jours que les débats sont très animés
autour de ce sujet ça encore été le cas
hier de quoi s'agit-il d'une note
confidentielle du Conseil d'État dans
laquelle il les mettrai des sur la
constitutionnalité de la réforme la note
et privée mais la gauche demande au
gouvernement de la publier pour éclairer
les débats il pourrait y avoir de
nombreuses prises de parole ou rappelle
aux règlements à ce sujet normalement
Tam nous pourrions attaquer l'article 2
cet après-midi l'article 2 c'est celui
sur l'index seniors souvenez-vous
l'Assemblée nationale l'avait supprimé
mais comme elle n'a pas examiné le texte
jusqu'au bout qu'elle ne l'a pas voté
l'index au senior fait son retour dans
le texte du Gouvernement que le Sénat
examine il y a donc de l'enjeu sur cette
question à savoir ce que la chambre
haute va faire de l'index seniors merci
merci beaucoup Audrey bien sûr on vous
retrouve tout au long de cette journée
pour vos analyses pour vos décryptage et
pour leur on a entendu à la cloche qui
sonnait pendant votre intervention la
séance vient de commencer nous sommes en
sommes encore à l'examen des articles
additionnels après l'article premier et
c'est un amendement des communistes qui
va être débattue un amendement
directement tiré de la commission
d'enquête sur les cabinet de conseils et
notamment mackenza les sénateurs
communistes veulent savoir le rôle qu'a
joué ce cabinet de conseils dans
l'élaboration de cette réforme des
retraites et puis également il va y
avoir des discussions sur l'introduction
d'une part de capitalisation dans notre
système de retraite un sujet sur
laquelle la droite vous ouvrir une porte
et auquel la gauche est fermement
opposée tout de suite on prend la
direction de l'hémicycle notre ordre du
jour rappelle la suite de la discussion
des projets de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale
nous sommes parvenus à l'abonnement à un
numéro
4469 rectifier bis tendant insérer un
article après l'article 1 et
c'est amendement est présenté par le
président Laurent monsieur le président
merci monsieur le Président je présente
cet amendement au nom de la présidente
assassy qui regrette de ne pas pouvoir
être parmi nous à l'heure où nous en
parlons
957 674 euros et 20 centimes c'est le
montant de la prestation du cabinet
conseil McKinsey pour la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse
l'objectif préparait les transformations
de la caisse après la réforme des
retraites sauf que ces prestations de
conseils interviennent avant la réforme
par point abandonné depuis de ces
prestations il ne reste rien ou
quasiment rien un PowerPoint et un
carnet de 50 pages qui ferait office de
solde de tout compte monsieur le
ministre des documents existent il va
falloir les communiquer largement à la
représentation nationale à la société
civile et à nos concitoyens sinon il ne
peut y avoir que défiance et suspicieux
je ne pourrais vous rappeler en
paraphrasant certainement du
gouvernement plus prompte à en juin les
Français à travailler plus longtemps
qu'à faire respecter les contrats des
firmes privées
travail mérite salaire mais tout salaire
mérite travail c'est donc le moment de
nous dire s'il y a eu presque un million
d'euros sans travail j'ai entendu le
président de la CNAV monsieur Renaud
Villars se féliciter de ses prestations
il a déclaré devant la commission des
affaires sociales j'aurais été
irresponsable si je n'avais pas pris le
temps de me faire assister par une aide
extérieure pour anticiper un tel choc la
CNAV a bien évidemment des compétences
et des conseils en interne mais pas pour
absorber une telle transformation ainsi
donc avec une masse salariale de la CNAV
de 1,4 milliards d'euros il n'y a
personne d'assez compétent pour y
préparer une réforme des retraites nous
demandons donc avec cet amendement un
rapport qui permet de faire la lumière
sur cet épisode un rapport qui souhaite
établir si le gouvernement a recouru au
cabinet conseil pour cette réforme tant
dans son argumentation
que pour ses conseils en stratégie je
vous le demande monsieur le ministre des
cabinets conseils ont-ils directement ou
indirectement participer à l'élaboration
de la réforme des retraites que nous
discutons aujourd'hui
la vie de la commission
madame la rapporteur général oui bonjour
monsieur le Président Monsieur le min
chers collègues alors nos avis sur
l'ensemble des demandes de rapport est
toujours la même je voulais
malheureusement annoncer dès les
premiers jours il y a pas plus
d'indulgence pour le demande de rapport
qui viennent de ce côté-là que de ce
côté-là cette avis des favorable
cependant sur ce rapport qui a demandé
par votre groupe monsieur le Président
je vous l'ai indiqué que chacun peut se
rappeler du travail important qui a été
fait au Sénat sous la présidence de
Madame Eliana Sassi présidente et donc
je pense que on peut demander l'avis du
gouvernement pour connaître les réponses
à vos questions en tout cas c'est un
avis défavorable comme pour les autres
gouvernement je voulais prévenir que
nous sommes saisis d'une demande de
scrutin public voilà
monsieur le ministre merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président Madame le
Président de la Commission madame et
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
de manière générale et je dis à
descendre de manière générale puisqu'il
c'est principe souffre toujours
d'exception le gouvernement donne
généralement un avis défavorable aux
demandes de rapport considérant que
certains peuvent avoir un intérêt c'est
pour ça que je dis qu'il y a quelques
exceptions mais que pour la plupart cela
relève du travail de contrôle du
Parlement sur le gouvernement et
d'ailleurs madame la rapporteur général
à l'instant il viendra rappeler les
travaux de la commission d'enquête
présidé par votre collègue madame la
Présidente assassin qui avait permis
aussi un débat public et qui a
d'ailleurs permis qui ont permis un
certain nombre d'évolution dans les
pratiques je ne cite qu'un exemple que
je connais bien puisque c'est le
ministère d'angélateur de la préparation
du PLF pour 2023 j'ai obtenu un certain
nombre d'emplois d'équivalentes en plein
pour permettre au sein de la Direction
générale de l'emploi et de la formation
professionnelle de réintégrer et donc de
réinternaliser pardon pour ce néologisme
un certain nombre de prestations qui
jusqu'à présent était analyser des
cabinets conseils donc la vie est
défavorable sur le rapport pour cette
question de principe pour répondre à
votre question mon cabinet la direction
la sécurité sociale qui sont les deux
administrations pardonnez-moi une
administration et un cabinet qui ont
élaboré ce projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale a été
rectificatif l'ont fait en interne sans
recours à des prestations de conseils
les administrations vous le savez on
recourt à des prestations de conseil
parfois sur des marchés structurants
parfois sur des marchés ponctuels mais
en l'occurrence pour la préparation du
PLFSS rectificatif que nous vous
souhaitons c'est un travail qui a été
réalisé en interne c'est d'ailleurs un
des avantages de passer par ce type de
véhicule particulièrement connu et
maîtriser nos administrations
merci je voudrais préciser que madame la
Présidente associé était la rapporteur
et elle s'était présidée par le
président Arnaud Bazin donc par rapport
à la référence à ce travail du Sénat
et si on veut
madame Lubin
moi je voudrais
rajouter non je n'ai rien à rajouter
mais un petit peu
je voudrais rebondir sur sur
l'amendement de nos collègues du CRCE
parce que
nous savons bien évidemment que le
gouvernement a eu énormément recours à
ses cabinets conseils à tel point que
nous nous demandons à quoi servent tous
les tous les comités tous les groupes
paraministériels et ainsi de suite qui
existent aujourd'hui et les
administrations bien évidemment et qui
sont censés quand même faire tout ce
travail préparatoire j'espère que en
matière de retraite
vous puiserez suffisamment sur ce qui
existe dans ce qui existe déjà je veux
parler notamment du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui réunit
toutes les grandes administrations
concernées par ce sujet là j'espère que
si un jour il y avait une véritable
réforme des retraites on commencerait
par interroger ceux qui connaissent le
sujet depuis longtemps merci
monsieur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues merci
monsieur le ministre pour votre réponse
on l'entend on nous dit que vous avez
une volonté de réinternaliser un certain
nombre de
postes sur les notamment sur les
conseils nous serons extrêmement
vigilants sur les prochaines semaines
les prochains mois les prochaines
réformes et nous vous encourageons à
réinternaliser un certain nombre de
compétences à l'intérieur des ministères
donc continuons sur cette bonne voie
mais je reprends la parole après le
président Laurent nous demandions un
rapport pour connaître précisément
en quoi avait consisté
la prestation du cabinet de conseil
McKinsey pour une somme de
674 euros précisément sur notamment sur
cette question de retraite où nous nous
dites que sur le budget rectificatif
mackinsey ou un autre cabinet de
conseils ne sont pas intervenus mais en
quoi à consister donc le montant de
cette prestation indiqué retraite pour
957000 674 euros vous nous avez répondu
nous vous encourageons là dans la même
veine à nous répondre précisément sur
cette question je vous remercie monsieur
le Président merci nous allons passer
maintenant au vote scrutin public
je vais déclarer le scrutin public fixé
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
voilà une première demande de scrutin
public sur le premier amendement qui est
débattu ce matin un amendement qui je
vous le rappelle est un amendement des
communistes et qui est directement
entirée de la commission d'enquête
sénatoriales sur les cabinets de
conseils et cette amendement vise
particulièrement le cabinet mackenzée je
vous rappelle et bien que ce cette
commission d'enquête avait pour
rapporteur la présidente du groupe
communiste et liane assassy elle était
présidé par le sénateur les républicains
arano Bazin ce qui avait permis
d'élaborer dans l'ensemble des
conclusions qui avaient été tout à fait
consensuel sur l'ensemble du Sénat alors
cette fois-ci concernant cet amendement
les sénateurs communistes qui ont
également l'appui des socialistes vous
avez entendu la prise de parole de la
socialiste Monique Lubin demande et bien
comment ont été utilisés cette
prestation de conseils qui est autour de
1 million d'euros de makit Zay et qui
il faut rappeler les chiffres
au début de la mise en place de ce
système de répartition en 1945 nous
étions 6 actifs pour un retraité
aujourd'hui nous en sommes à 1,7 actif
certaines projections nous donnent 1,2
actif dans 15 ans et nous avons un pic
démographique
d'actifs en 2040 et nous perdons au fur
et à mesure on parle de moins 30 %
d'actifs à horizon
2045 alors cette inexorable déclin de
cette pyramide des âges nous amène à
dire la vérité aux Français je crains
fort que la mesure d'âge qui était
exposée à l'article 7 et qui est
nécessaire et indispensable pour
préserver notre système de répartition
ne soit pas suffisant pour pérenniser
définitivement ce système auquel nous
tenons tous ici puisque c'est la
solidarité intergénérationnelle c'est la
raison pour laquelle à travers cet
amendement d'appel
je demande au gouvernement avec un bon
nombre de mes collègues à penser un
nouveau système qui en fait couperait le
système de répartition qui serait en
fait le minimum garanti en termes de
retraite avec un système de
capitalisation je pense que c'est aussi
une mesure de justice sociale puisque 8
millions d'actifs aujourd'hui ont déjà
bénéficié déjà d'un système de
capitalisation on parle de trois et demi
dans le public et 4 et demi dans le
privé et puis dernier mot pays européen
voisins l'ont déjà fait et ont pu
préserver leur système de répartition
parce qu'aucun de ces pays n'a passé
d'un système de répartition un système
de capitation je vous remercie merci
sur le rapporteur général ils sont
sur il va présenter l'amendement et s'il
veut bien les 6 ou amendements qui qui
vont avec donc
je vais vous donner une responsabilité
il va pas au-delà de vos capacités mais
mais au-delà du règlement c'est vrai
qu'il est gentiment sous amendé oui
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues
d'abord peut-être une question de forme
monsieur le ministre il est bien dommage
que vous ayez choisi une procédure
rétrécie et très contrainte pour parler
d'un dossier comme celui des retraites
[Applaudissements]
je le dis je le dis avec à la fois
solanité et une forme de gravité parce
que sur un sujet comme celui-ci qui
concerne à la fois l'étape suivante plus
de 4 décennies de travail lorsque on
prend sa pension et qu'on se projette
dans l'avenir c'est à la fois une
garantie et un retour sur la promesse
faite aux salariés aux indépendants et
aux fonctionnaires le retour finalement
de leur contribution par le travail
deuxième élément je pense qu'on est
aussi dans un temps de vérité Stéphane
Le Rue dulier vient de le rappeler le
mouvement démographique est implacable
nous aurons moins de cotisants plus de
bénéficiaires puisque nous avons une
espérance de vie qui augmente et une
espérance de vie de nos concitoyens en
bonne santé donc on a ce devoir de
regarder de quelle manière soit le
système de répartition perdure à lui
seul et malheureusement
on va inexorablement soit vers une
baisse des pensions sur le lait seul
soit vers une augmentation des
cotisations ce qui est proposé à travers
ma demande d'un rapport c'est finalement
d'avoir un porté à connaissance sur
l'impact que pourrait avoir à l'exemple
à l'exemple d'un système universel
obligatoire de capitalisation de
provisionnement collectif finalement la
contribution de l'ensemble des des
salariés et des indépendants pourquoi
parce qu'en fait c'est le meilleur moyen
de consolider et de faire en sorte que
les pensions qui commencent à être
versées soit les plus proches possible
des revenus d'activités et c'est
notamment un phénomène et un enjeu de
justice sociale parce que par cette
méthode ce sont d'abord et surtout les
rémunérations les plus basses qui
profiteront de cet effort selon nous la
demande que nous demandons de rapport
le sous amendement
4735 madame Lubin
l'amendement de nos collègues de la
majorité sénatoriale est tellement
intéressante que nous l'avons sous
amendée parce que
et c'est un débat fort intéressant que
nous allons avoir j'ai l'impression que
vous ne faites tellement plus confiance
à cette retraite par répartition vous
allez voter ce projet de loi qui nous
dit qu'il va sauver la retraite par les
partitions mais vous n'avez tellement
plus confiance à la retraite par
répartition que vous voulez faire voter
que vous voulez voir venir des systèmes
de capitalisation et vous venez de nous
expliquer que c'est finalement ce qui
serait le plus juste pour les salariés
mais nous nous disons que ça serait le
plus injuste et surtout le plus
dangereux le plus injuste pourquoi parce
que partout où il y a des systèmes de
capitalisation avec une base minimale de
répartition et tout le reste en
capitalisation nous savons que la nous
savons que la base est minimale est
extrêmement minimale surtout pour les
plus petits revenus
et les retraites par capitalisation
enfin regardons ce qui se passe
actuellement regardons l'histoire toutes
les crises qu'il y a eu à chaque fois
qu'il y a eu des crises financières
importantes que les bourses se sont
cassées la figure que et bien qui a payé
en premier regardez ce qui s'est passé
notamment aux États-Unis mais ce sont
les retraités qui paient en premier il
ne faut surtout pas donner aux salariés
l'illusion qu'ils pourront se construire
une retraite par capitalisation qui
pourra le faire qui pourra le faire ce
qui le font déjà c'est à dire ceux qui
ont les revenus les plus importants mais
demandez aujourd'hui à quelqu'un qui
gagne le SMIC ou même un petit peu plus
que plus que le SMIC de
d'économiser puisque c'est de ça donc il
s'agit de l'argent pour pour atteindre
des je vais en parler après pour
éventuellement se payer sa retraite plus
tard c'est illusoire quant au plan
épargne retraite c'est une belle façon
de détourner de ne pas augmenter les
salaires merci
d'amendement madame Cohen le présente
sous amendement
des collègues du groupe communiste
républicain citoyens
on est contre la capitalisation mais on
va saisir de l'amendement de notre
collègue pour essayer d'améliorer les
choses et de vous montrer en quoi vous
vous fourvoyez au Chili ce système de
retraite par capitalisation privée
individuelle promettait dans les années
80 de partir à la retraite avec 100 % de
ses revenus et une meilleure efficacité
que le système de réparer de répartition
soit les mêmes arguments que les vôtres
40 ans plus tard la réalité pour les
chiliennes et les chiliens et tout autre
en 2019 les retraites s'élevaient à 288
euros en moyenne avec une importante
différence entre les pensions moyennes
des hommes et celles des femmes dans un
pays qui a un niveau de vie proche de
celui du Portugal les montants des
retraites sont donc faibles et la
plupart des personnes âgées doivent
trouver un emploi informel pour subvenir
à leurs besoins quand il a été mis en
place en 80 c'était sous la dictature de
Pinochet l'administration des fonds de
pension était perçues comme un modèle
novateur qui faisait figure d'exception
avant cette date les Chiliens cotisaient
un fond commun géré par l'État proche du
système système de retraite par
répartition aujourd'hui il dépose chaque
mois environ 10% de leur rémunération
salaire ou revenu imposables sur un
compte personnel auprès d'un
administrateur de fonds de pension
l'objectif est que ces investissements
génèrent des rendements pour qu'à la fin
de leur vie active les retraités
puissent profiter à la fois du capital
apporter et des gains accumulés
malheureusement le modèle chilien
montrait ses limites en 2018 le CD
considérait le Chili comme l'une des
cinq économies mondiales au plus bas
taux de remplacement autrement dit un
travailleur chilien qui part à la
retraite subit une des plus grandes
pertes de pouvoir d'achat pour ces
raisons donc nous demandons mes chers
collègues de mentionner cette cet
exemple dans votre rapport et j'espère
qu'il vous fera réfléchir
4745 madame Vogel le présente
alors timon nous sommes comme mes
collègues l'ont dit opposés au modèle de
retraite par capitalisation mais au
moins il nous donne l'occasion d'avoir
un débat sur ce que ça impliquerait et
cet amendement propose que dans cette
éventuelle rapport soit ajouté une étude
de l'impact négatif de ce qu'est un
modèle de retraite par capitalisation
sur le réchauffement climatique et plus
largement la crise environnementale que
nous subissons le modèle par
capitalisation au-delà d'être un modèle
qui est individualiste ou les personnes
cotisent enfin investissent pour leur
propre avenir et donc ont tendance à
investir dans dans ce qui est le plus
rentable à court terme est aussi un
modèle qui se fonde sur les
investissements des fonds de pension
auront c'est pour prendre un exemple le
plus gros fond de privé Black Rock qui
existe dans le monde ils ont investi en
2022 259 milliards 259 milliards d'euros
dans les énergies fossiles
or on sait très bien je pense qu'au
moins là-dessus on peut avoir un accord
ici les énergies fossiles les
investissements dans les fossiles sont
les investissements dans la destruction
de notre planète et dans la destruction
de ce qui fait au fond de notre capacité
à vivre ensemble plus tard donc un
modèle de retraite par capitalisation en
dehors du fait que c'est un modèle
individualiste c'est aussi un modèle qui
est au fond c'est équivaut
financer notre avenir collectif en
investissant dans sa destruction donc
nous pensons que six rapports il y a
là-dessus il devra en priorité mesurer
les impacts négatifs des fonds privés
dans la destruction de la planète parce
que vous savez s'il y a plus de planètes
il y aura plus d'humains pour y prendre
leur retraite
merci le sous amendement 4746 madame
ponce le présente
voilà vous le voyez dessinateurs
débattent à partir d'un amendement
d'appel un présenté par les sénateurs LR
pour coupler le système parle partition
à un système par capitalisation Stéphane
Le redulliez a dit notamment que 8
millions d'actifs aujourd'hui sont déjà
concernés en France et Audrey et bien
c'est aussi l'occasion d'entendre très
clairement toute l'opposition de la
gauche oui alors Tam je vais peut-être
vous expliquer ce qu'est la retraite par
capitalisation il faut savoir que la
France a toujours fait le choix inverse
avec une retraite par répartition la
répartition qu'est-ce que c'est ça veut
dire que les actifs d'aujourd'hui
financent les retraites des retraités
actuels mais ce n'est pas un secret pour
personne on fait face à une chute
démographique qui fait quand que quand
en 2004 nous avions deux actifs pour
payer la retraite d'un retraité
aujourd'hui nous avons à peu près 1,7
actifs pour financer la retraite d'un
retraité chez nos voisins européens il
existe une autre méthode la retraite par
capitalisation concrètement ça veut dire
que les salariés et les employeurs
investissent individuellement leur
cotisations dans des fonds
d'investissement ou dans des actions et
que les pensions sont ensuite liées aux
performances de ces investissements pour
certains sénateurs de droite on arrive à
un moment un c'est indispensable de
d'intégrer pardon une dose de
capitalisation dans notre système pour
les sénateurs de gauche ils ne veulent
pas l'entendre ils estiment que ça
remettrait en cause tout notre système
et que ça ne profiterait qu'au plus
riche Tab merci merci beaucoup Audrey
pour toutes ces explications là
rejoindre à l'hémicycle ou les
discussions se poursuivent sur
l'introduction d'une dose de
capitalisation dans notre système de
retraite par répartition ou une mesure à
laquelle s'oppose de nombreux sénateurs
de gauche c'est Raymonde poncemont
aujourd'hui écologiste qui prend
actuellement la parole elle va être
suivie par des sénateurs du groupe
communiste on prend donc la direction de
l'hémicycle
l'amendement de 47 47
excusez-moi merci monsieur le Président
de notre sous-amendement vise à
supprimer les deux dernières phrases de
l'amendement alors ma collègue Laurence
Cohen l'a dit
l'amendement 1968 nous sommes contre la
capitalisation et ça vous le savez tout
est tout nous estimons qu'étudier les
modalités restauration d'un nouveau
régime social applicable à des
cotisations versées un régime
obligatoire d'assurance vieillesse par
capitalisation destinée aux salariés aux
indépendants qui seraient intégrés dans
le système de retraite sans aucun débat
démocratique avec les Français et les
parlementaires évidemment n'est pas
acceptable une telle modification du
système de retraite ne peut se faire
sans une consultation du peuple au
préalable définir une structure
administrative qui pourrait être retenue
pour piloter ce nouveau régime
obligatoire ces modalités de financement
la composition de son conseil
d'administration ainsi que les règles
entourant les placements de ses actifs
donne évidemment la l'impression que la
réforme est déjà dans le kart dans les
cartons et qu'il suffit d'une nouvelle
majorité politique pour que cette
réforme soit faite l'amendement justifie
la pertinence d'une dose de
capitalisation dans notre système de
retraite par l'exemple de l'agir Carco
alors que les cadres ont dû accepter une
heure de leur cotisation salariale nous
contestons l'introduction de la
capitalisation dans notre système de
répartition dont les fondements reposent
sur la solidarité entre les actifs et
les retraités si la démographie modifie
l'équilibre entre les actifs et les
retraités il faudrait augmenter la
cotisation des employeurs pour garantir
l'équilibre du système je vous remercie
si l'amendement 47
41 monsieur Julias le présente
présent monsieur le président
nous avons bien compris avec non
nous avons bien compris avec le débat
qui qui s'amorce que le projet
gouvernemental finalement et le
préambule a un projet une réforme
beaucoup plus importante qui est celle
que vous avancez chers cocktail chers
collègue c'est la réforme des retraites
par capitalisation ce qu'on est en train
de discuter c'est la première étape la
deuxième étape là elle est en discussion
au Sénat c'est la capitalisation je
partage les arguments qui ont été
exposés ici j'aimerais en rajouter un
qui est celui de l'OFCE qui est un une
remarque très forte je cite une
génération qui remettrait en cause le
système serait spolié puisqu'elle
devrait être à la fois assuré une
retraite à ses parents et se constituer
un capital pour financer sa retraite par
capitalisation donc le changement de du
de la retraite par répartition à la
retraite plusieurs capitalisation ça
c'est un problème pour les pour les
jeunes générations les jeunes
générations sont obligés de porter une
une double charge ce qui est un vrai
problème le second problème c'est que
vous êtes en train de faire des projets
sur la comète vous êtes en train de nous
dire que la capitalisation est
intéressante mais dans un monde où nous
nous savons rien de ce que sera
l'économie dans 30 ans ou l'économie
française est face à un changement
radical comment vous pouvez prévoir dans
20 ans ou dans 30 ans ce que seront ces
fonds de capitalisations et enfin une
une question pour pour Monsieur le
monsieur le ministre il existe un fond
de pension pour l'État c'est la retraite
additionnelle de la fonction publique
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire où on
est l'évolution de ce font particulier
et notamment un point important quelles
sont les conséquences de l'augmentation
des rémunérations accessoires des heures
supplémentaires sur le financement par
l'état de ce concours merci monsieur le
président
monsieur Étienne blanc pour l'amendement
1959 rectifié merci monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues et
l'amendement les deux amendements que
j'ai déposés sont dans la droite ligne
de ce que je soutiens depuis le début de
ce débat et il faut que nous ayons et
dans notre système de retraite une part
réservée à la capitalisation je l'ai
fait sur l'article liminaire et puis
ensuite par différents amendements moi
je voudrais dire trois choses très
rapidement la première chose la critique
qui est faite au système de
capitalisation mais c'est ça n'est pas
un système collectif mais le fond de
réserve pour les retraites c'est un
système collectif et qui interdit au
sein d'un système de capitalisation de
mettre des dispositions qui rendent plus
collectif l'usage de ce fond c'est
parfaitement faisable et un grand nombre
de pays européens le font il y a un pays
qui est un très bel exemple c'est la
Suisse
sur ce système mixte et sur le système
collectif la deuxième chose que je
voudrais dire c'est que
il ne faut pas être exclusif les
systèmes qui fonctionnent aujourd'hui en
Europe ce sont des systèmes mixtes une
part importante de répartition qui
garantit une retraite de base et une
part de capitalisation qui permet à tous
de bénéficier de la croissance et de la
richesse économique puis troisième sujet
mais c'est à ces extraordinaire
enfin moi j'ai regardé vos amendements
mes chers collègues de l'autre côté de
l'hémicycle vous refusez même refuser
même d'étudier le système vers
l'ouverture du dossier pour vous c'est
quasiment criminel mais enfin regardez
le monde autour de vous il y a des
systèmes qui marchent il y a des
systèmes qui fonctionnent et qui sont
ces systèmes mixtes
réfléchir ça devrait pas vous être
interdit quoi
étudier ça devrait pas vous être
interdit
comprendre le bon tel qu'il est ça
devrait pas vous être interdit voilà
pourquoi j'ai déposé ces deux
amendements qui me paraissent des
amendements de bon sens et qui devrait
recueillir évidemment l'agrément de
notre assemblée bien les deux
amendements ils ont été présentés et
défendu la vie de la commission les deux
rapporteurs vont exprimer
leur avis au nom de la commission madame
la rapporteur général oui
c'est un avis
les amendements
se
le sujet parce que c'est important aussi
qu'on puisse peser sous peser l'ensemble
des systèmes de retraite alors là le
texte qui nous incombe aujourd'hui sur
lequel nous débattons c'est un projet de
loi qui est sur des mesures
paramétriques sur le système de retraite
par répartition mais le fait que vous
posiez cette question est intéressante
parce que on le voit bien à travers les
sondages et je veux rappeler quelques
chiffres en fait dans une enquête
récente 63% des Français sont favorables
à la retraite par répartition 24% il
serait défavorable mais en fait
qu'est-ce que ça montre c'est que le
principe de répartition semble donc
majoritaire mais le système où chacun
préparerait sa retraite individuelle
recueillerait tout de même l'adhésion
d'une solide minorité
39% donc on peut dire 40%. alors que 56%
pas d'accord mais quels sont ceux qui
sont les plus d'accord bien c'est les
jeunes générations et on voit bien là ce
qu'on a dit depuis le début c'est que
les jeunes générations ne croient pas
dans notre système en tout cas il ne
croit pas dans le financement de notre
système donc c'est important qu'on en
parle et je crois que que le fait que
ces amendements arrivent là pour une
demande de rapport c'est aussi débattre
sur la question des retraites on
pourrait parler par exemple du système
Préfon pour la fonction publique qui est
un système par point aussi qui est
intéressant et c'est pas c'est pas
vraiment le sujet je dirais qu'on
s'exporte un petit peu par rapport à nos
débats depuis quelques jours mais c'est
une belle occasion quand même d'en
parler et je remercie tous ceux qui ont
posé ses amendements donc c'est un avis
défavorable
monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci c'est effectivement un avis
défavorable sur une demande de rapport
comme tous les avis sur les demandes de
rapport simplement je voudrais vous
faire part à moi de l'expérience que
j'ai comme rapporteur depuis quatre ans
sur ces projets de réforme et nous
avions eu à l'époque l'occasion avec
Monsieur Delvoye d'aller voir justement
pour se faire expérience ce qui se
passait à l'étranger et notamment on a
été Danemark Suède - Italie certains
même étaient nous accompagnés dans le
déplacement
suite del Mar Italie et Allemagne ce
qu'on peut retenir par rapport à cela
c'est tout à fait instructif nous avions
vu ces pays parce qu'ils avaient
justement des retraites à points ou en
compte notionnel et on a bien vu que à
travers la dimension de ce type de
système de régime de retraite notamment
à point c'est que quand vous avez pas
beaucoup de points une carrière
à faible revenu fait une pension à
faible revenu donc il faut faire être
très attentif déjà par rapport au
système par point et puis nous avions vu
également qu'il y avait eu dans
différents pays une volonté de faire en
sorte de trouver un système plus
égalitaire et d'essayer de supprimer les
régimes spéciaux ils n'y sont jamais
arrivés aucun pays n'a réussi à unifier
tout cela et puis nous avions vu
également que les systèmes de retraite
étaient souvent en base par répartition
mais les systèmes complémentaires
étaient gérés par les partenaires
sociaux sur un système par
capitalisation nous sommes les seuls en
France à avoir des partenaires sociaux
qui gèrent un système par répartition et
que dans la courbe qui a été faite je
revois très bien la courbe de
l'évolution justement des rendements de
ce système de retraite par répartition
par capitalisation par contre la courbe
est toujours montante quand vous
regardez sur le long terme avec des
hauts des effectivement des hauts et des
bas mais une coupe toujours ascendante
et nous avions retenu quoi comme bilan
c'est que 1 il me semble que nous
pouvons regarder cela parce que la
philosophie de ce type de système c'est
de ne pas mettre tous ses œufs dans le
même panier
une base par répartition un échange
supplémentaire par capitalisation et que
notre part il y a quelque chose de
commun dans ces régimes si on veut que
cela marche ce sont les fonds de réserve
ces régimes qu'ils soient répartition ou
en capitalisation ne peuvent marcher que
s'il y a des fonds de réserve c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut être
attentif et notamment nous dans notre
système français travaillé sur le fond
de réserve des retraites qu'il s'agirait
quand même dans un souci de garantie
pour nos jeunes de consolider une fois
qu'on a dit ça l'adaptation est
compliquée parce qu'il y a des
engagements par les régimes
complémentaires donc il faut regarder
nous sommes un pays où il y a des
prélèvements qui sont particulièrement
élevés il nous apporte de voir comment
on peut introduire éventuellement un
système qui garantirait qui garantirait
notre système de retraite qui donnerait
confiance à nos jeunes parce que quelle
est la réflexion quelle est la réflexion
de la plupart de nos concitoyens c'est
de dire j'ai suffisamment contribué j'en
ai payé quand même des cotisations j'ai
bien le droit à avoir un niveau de
retraite et ben ça c'est le raisonnement
par capitalisation plus que par
répartition les gens me semble-t-il sont
prêts c'est la raison pour laquelle
monsieur le ministre il est important
dans cette réflexion de commencer à
tranquillement aborder ce problème et le
rapport sur ce sujet de capitalisation
me paraît tout à fait intéressant
merci monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le Président comme
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
l'ont vu le gouvernement a fait le choix
de ne pas ouvrir le sujet de la
capitalisation dans ce projet loi de
financement la sécurité sociale et pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de suspense et
rejoignant ainsi la vie de Madame la
rapporteur général dès lors qu'il y a
demande de rapport il y a par principe
en tout cas de manière très générale un
avis défavorable par contre je voulais
saisir l'occasion de ces demandes de
rapport et tes amendements pour
souligner à la fois la complexité et
parfois
le fait que ce sujet de la
capitalisation réveille un certain
nombre de contradictions et des
contradictions qui peuvent toutes et
tous nous traverser lorsque j'entends
les défenseurs des sous amendements dire
qu'ils veulent limiter le champ du
rapport à un certain nombre d'aspects
pour ne pas ouvrir la question de la
capitalisation
ce sont les mêmes qu'hier dans une
logique de protection des régimes
spéciaux ont défendu le régime spécial
de la Banque de France qui est fondée
sur un système de capitalisation
collectif certainement mais le
capitalisation de la même manière nous
avons dans les concertations un certain
nombre de partenaire sociaux qui nous
ont dit leur hostilité au système de
capitalisation mais qui sont les mêmes
qui vont être amenés dans d'autres
sphères dans d'autres milieux
d'activités à les défendre voire allait
gérer il a été évoqué je crois par
Monsieur gay le système de retraite
additionnel de la fonction publique les
rafles pardon monsieur zoulias
pardonnez-moi ce système monsieur le
sénateur vous avez raison est un système
par capitalisation collective et vous
m'avez interrogé en me disant mais quel
est l'effet de l'augmentation de la part
des rémunérations accessoires ou
indemnitaires par rapport au financement
et à l'écrit financière
qui fait que l'assiette de cotisation au
titre du régime additionnel de la
fonction publique
des agents qui ont recours et limité par
la loi à 20% du traitement indiciaire
global des mêmes agents ce qui signifie
que quand bien même la part du revenu
des revenus indemnitaires ou
complémentaires accessoires augmente
l'assiette de cotisation reste plafonnée
à 20% du régime indemnitaire mais votre
question sur les rêves appelle à une
autre marque qui renvoie cette
contradiction qui peut traverser
certains partenaires sociaux c'est que
si les rafles pétant régime arrêté par
la loi et fondé sur la capitalisation
collective il y a un autre régime de
capitalisation qui s'adresse à la
fonction publique qui est Préfon qui
intégralement géré par les partenaires
sociaux de la fonction publique et lui
fonder sur un système d'assurance vie ou
de capitalisation avec une nature
purement individuelle proposée aux
agents et qui recueillent plutôt un
véritable succès et puis enfin en termes
de contradiction et cela nous concerne
tous en réalité
souvent les premiers contenteurs des
régimes par capitalisation sont aussi
ceux qui parlent leur vie par leur
parcours personnel ont la possibilité
d'avoir recours à un certain nombre
d'assurance vie qui en fonction de la
manière dont elles sont liquidées
ressemblent quand même étrangement à des
systèmes par capitalisation dès lors que
l'on fait le choix d'une rencontre
mensuelle plutôt qu'un inversement
d'inversement de capital enfin j'ajoute
une interrogation personnelle qui est
que nous savons tous et nous avons tous
comme volonté d'ailleurs si nous n'avons
pas ouvert le sujet capitalisation c'est
parce que nous avons comme priorité la
préservation du système par répartition
par répartition et en particulier sa
caractère intergénérationnel mais nous
avons tous des interrogations et y
compris sur l'évolution de démographique
que l'on va connaître parfois même avec
une incapacité à la prévoir
véritablement à très long terme et
l'interrogation qui est la mienne mais
dont je répète qu'elle est totalement
personnelle
c'est que si les équilibres
démographiques venaient tant encore plus
se détériorer la question que nous
devrions nous poser collectivement par
pure principe de solidarité c'est celle
de la capacité des plus modestes à
garantir et à céder eux-mêmes à garantir
un niveau de revenus conséquent parce
que je n'ai absolument aucune inquiétude
pour ceux qui ont les revenus les plus
élevés et qui dansent déjà ont la
capacité de capitaliser ou en tout cas
de théoriser pour assurer leur avenir et
enfin pardon monsieur le Président je
suis un peu long mais un dernier mot
pour dire que
au-delà des rapports pour lesquels je le
répète il y a un avis défavorable de
principe nous avons une autre difficulté
dans ce domaine de la capitalisation qui
tient la complexité des systèmes
tous les systèmes qui ont recours à la
capitalisation sont particulièrement
complexes et sont des systèmes mixtes je
l'illustre avec le système suédois
au-delà des appréciations portées sur
les bornes d'âge mais le système suédois
que tout le monde présente de manière
assez rapide comme un système qui est
cumule la solidarité la répartition
pardon avec la capitalisation en réalité
c'est un système à trois voir quatre
étages avec une cotisation versée par
les salariés et tenez vous bien pardon
pour l'expression cette cotisation est
répartie en deux codes parts et le
salarié suédois c'est que la cote par
principale est affectée un système de
répartition mais doit lui-même choisir
parmi une liste de 40 fonds de pension
ou fonds de capitalisation
celui ou ceux sur lesquels il souhaite
que ça code par consacré la
capitalisation soit consacrée et à
défaut il y a un choix par défaut la
deuxième le deuxième étage est un étage
conventionnel et le troisième étage est
composé d'une possibilité de
capitalisation à titre individuel et
j'ajoute enfin une dernière complexité
mais le système suédois mis invite c'est
que parfois aussi dans ce débat la
confusion peut être faite ou en tout cas
une absence de distinction peut-être
entretenu entre ce qui relève d'un
système de capitalisation qui s'appuie
uniquement sur les fonds de pension
privée avec un intérêt totalement
lucratif et d'autres fonds de pension
qui peuvent s'appuyer sur des fonds
souverains qui par définition permettent
évidemment la mise en place de réserves
et de garantie pour les épargnants la
complexité du système nous oblige à y
travailler pas dans ce cadre de ce texte
de loi je l'ai dit mais je crois que
personne ne peut raisonnablement dire
qu'il n'y a pas de réflexion à avoir sur
le sujet de la capitalisation
merci nous allons maintenant passer au
vote avant de donner la parole pour les
explications de vote je suis saisi de 5
demandes de scrutin public
pour
l'ensemble des amendements et sous
amendements je vous en donnerai les
détails au fur et à mesure du vote et
pour que vous puissiez vous préparer
je
je explication de votre monsieur
chanterelle
et Madame Linde se prépare
voilà on passe donc aux explications de
vote sur cette amendement d'appel du
groupe LR pour réfléchir au fait de
coupler le système pas répartition avec
un système par capitalisation on a vu de
nombreux sous-amendements de la gauche
qui elles se pose fermement à ce sujet
et puis il y a eu des moments assez
houleux on a entendu par exemple le
sénateur LR du Rhône Étienne blanc dit
réfléchir ça devrait pas vous être
interdit et on a entendu que cela
faisait réagir dans l'hémicycle je vous
rappelle qu'il y a un avis défavorable
de la commission sur cet amendement
également un avis défavorable du
gouvernement Audrey on a entendu en tout
cas une opposition ferme entre la droite
et la gauche sur ce sujet oui on appuie
suivre des débats extrêmement
intéressants sur la forme de nos
retraites à la suite de cet amendement
de Stéphane le rubellier sénateur LR qui
estime qu'il faut introduire une dose de
capitalisation dans notre système de
retraite la capitalisation je vous le
rappelle confinement c'est quand salarié
et employeur investissent
individuellement les cotisations dans
des fonds de pension la retraite dépend
des performances de ces investissements
s'est en place chez nos voisins
européens mais la France historiquement
n'a jamais fait ce choix elle a toujours
préféré la répartition quand les actifs
financent les retraites des retraités
mais pour les sénateurs LR certains
sénateurs LR il faut un mix il faut
absolument une dose de capitalisation
pour préserver le système à gauche on
est vent debout contre cette idée qui
remettrait en cause tout notre système
qui pourrait créer des problèmes
environnementaux écoutez les arguments
pour avec Stéphane Le rudulier et les
arguments contre avec la sénatrice
socialiste Monique Lubin
je demande au gouvernement avec un bon
nombre de mes collègues à penser un
nouveau système qui en fait couperait le
système de répartition qui serait en
fait le minimum garanti en termes de
retraite avec un système de
capitalisation je pense que c'est aussi
une mesure de justice sociale puisque 8
millions d'actifs aujourd'hui ont déjà
bénéficié déjà d'un système de
capitalisation vous venez de nous
expliquer que c'est finalement ce qui
serait le plus juste pour les salariés
mais nous nous disons que ça serait le
plus injuste
te toutes les crises qu'il y a eu à
chaque fois qu'il y a eu des crises
financières importantes qui a payé en
premier regardez ce qui s'est passé
notamment aux États-Unis mais ce sont
les retraités
la commission a émis un avis défavorable
estimant que ce texte n'est pas le lieu
ni l'endroit d'y réfléchir même si elle
a trouvé que l'idée était plutôt bonne à
vie défavorable aussi du gouvernement
nous en sommes aux explications de votre
Sam effectivement nous sommes dans les
explications de vote où on voit encore
que c'est la gauche qui prend plutôt la
parole sur ce sujet après le sénateur
socialiste Yann chanterel c'est autour
de Marie à Noël linman de s'exprimer
pour ses explications de vote et je vous
rappelle qu'il va y avoir un scrutin
public un 5 demandes de scrutin public
autour et bien du vote de ces
amendements et sous amendements
quelle différence avec une cotisation
la différence c'est que vous pensez que
le placement financier va être plus
rentable que l'évolution salariale
et donc vous faites Paris d'une société
où la financiarisation continue à nous
vider de notre substance et de vider le
monde du travail de sa rémunération ce
pari là en plus vous essayez de faire
que les gens soient solidaires oh bah
quand même il faudrait pas que ma
retraite par capitalisation diminue
pendant ce temps-là vous baissez leur
salaire ou en tout cas vous les
augmentez pas donc c'est un choix
société majeur deuxièmement est-ce que
c'est un choix de bon père de famille et
ben non certes le rapporteur dit il y a
des yoyos mais en tendance lourdes ça
monte sauf que pendant le yoyo qui c'est
qui paye
la bonne mesure quand on sait qu'on va
avoir des trous d'air dans les
ressources c'était le fond de réserve
qui est une forme de placement collectif
mais qui je vous rappelle n'était pas
abondé par des cotisations mais par un
prélèvement sur des richesses gagner par
le pays alors on pourra discuter des
manières de ces faits mais qui était
justement de se dire l'airbag du système
de retraite on le prélève sur les
richesses pour se donner les moyens
collectifs
monsieur Lecomte
merci monsieur le Président c'est un peu
étonnant hier dans un quasi silence on a
vous avez voté des reculs sociaux
importants et des efforts pour les
Français et vous allez continuer et
pourtant aujourd'hui vous nous dites ça
suffira pas ça le problème c'est quand
même un peu inquiétant et puis
concernant ce sujet de la capitalisation
alors moi je vais me concentrer sur la
manière dont vous imaginez le faire
parce que soit c'est quelque chose en
plus et d'obligatoire et là pour le coup
il faut trouver des moyens de financer
soit c'est une partie de ce qui est
aujourd'hui la répartition qui passe
vers la capitalisation et à ce moment-là
il faut nous expliquer comment dans ce
cas là vous allez financer des retraites
par répartition c'est une partie de ce
qui va vers les systèmes par répartition
aujourd'hui va demain vers un système de
capitalisation ce qui veut dire qu'en
fait le système par répartition sera
fragilisé par ailleurs dans les pays où
ça fonctionne dans les pays où ça
fonctionne dans les pays où plutôt ça
existe
il n'y a pas de fiscalité sur ce qui va
vers la capitalisation dans la plupart
des cas bon et dans ce cas là ça veut
dire que les plus aisés
ont une solution pour finalement ne pas
payer d'impôts le jour où il gagne mais
le jour où il perçoivent cette rente lié
alors capitalisation je ne crois pas que
compte tenu de les finances publiques
aujourd'hui il soit souhaitable que les
personnes les plus aisées du pays soit
en capacité de ne pas payer d'impôts
aujourd'hui pour les avoir les pays dans
30 ans en plus sur le fond si vous
voulez éviter que ça représente trop de
risques c'est-à-dire que ce soit pas
justement du capitaliste mais une vraie
capitalisation à ce moment-là il faut
mettre une partie de l'argent dans des
obligations de l'État bon ça veut dire
qu'il faut faire de la dette bon et
deuxièmement ça veut dire qu'il faut
passer une partie de cet argent
dans des dans des biens dont on sait
qu'il garderont de la valeur et en
particulier dans l'immobilier et à
partir de là ça veut dire que des des
biens des biens qui sont essentiels à la
dignité pour conclure et bien c'est va
devenir des éléments de d'investissement
et de spéculation et ça ce n'est pas la
société que nous voulons monsieur gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues moi je suis
ravi que il y ait des failles dans
l'obstruction silencieuse de nos
collègues de droite parce que pour notre
plus grand plaisir
on a un débat ce matin et pour faire un
débat il faut être deux il y a deux
projets de société qui s'affrontent pas
de problème
il y a la répartition versus la
capitalisation et vous le dites et vous
le dit très bien pour vous cette réforme
n'est qu'une étape pour reprendre le
chemin de 2019 et au bout de deux ou
trois ans revenir et redire il faut la
capitalisation individuelle pour tous et
toutes c'est ça votre volonté c'est de
remettre la main sur les 346 milliards
de cotisations sociales qui échappent
chaque année au capital pour les
remettre dans les mains du marché pour
Blackrock et compagnie très bien mais je
remercie monsieur le rue dulier et c'est
40 collègues de poser la question et
nous avons un débat et vous avez compris
que pour nous c'est non et juste
puisqu'il me reste 52 secondes il faut
qu'on ait un débat sur argument contre
argument je le dis à Monsieur le
rugulier la raison oui nous avons moins
d'actifs aujourd'hui qu'en 1945 ou en
1980 je crois qu'en 1980 c'était 3,7
3,actif pour un retraité aujourd'hui le
chiffre est 1,7 oui mais en 1980
un travailleur une travailleuse elle
produisait 25000 euros de richesse en
moyenne combien aujourd'hui 80
000 euros c'est à dire la productivité
les gains de productivité c'est froid
3,2 mais où sont passés ces gains de
productivité pas dans les salaires donc
je vous pose la question pendant les
niveaux de pension de retraite où sont
passés les gains de productivité en 40
ans 10 points ont été volés au travail
par le capital voilà la réalité
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Laurence Rossignol
merci monsieur le Président mon
explication de vote est sur le 174 à cet
instant madame la rapporteur vous nous
avez dit il y a un instant la preuve
qu'il faudra un jour aller vers un
régime par capitalisation vous avez pas
soutenu l'amendement mais vous avez
quand même laissé clairement entrevoir
votre position c'est que les jeunes sont
les plus méfiants à l'égard ne sème de
répartition hier de rapporteur René Paul
Savary nous disait attention à force
d'insister sur la pénibilité de certains
métiers on finit par cesser de les
rendre attractifs je vous suggère
d'appliquer la recommandation de René
Paul Savary à la question des retraites
à force de dire aux jeunes que le
système est plombé on finit
effectivement par leur faire perdre
conscience dans le système mais je
voudrais simplement dire une chose en
fait c'est pas des retraites qu'on parle
c'est du marché c'est de l'injonction
permanente qui est faite par les
cabinets conseils anglo-saxons dont
gouvernement raffole par les instituts
libéraux qui nous dit on a besoin des
fonds de pension en France et la
question qu'il faut qu'on se c'est ce
qu'on veut donner au fond spéculatif
l'argent que les salariés consacrent
aujourd'hui par répartition à leur
retraite de demain et alors je vais me
dire plus loin est-ce que c'est
l'intérêt des salariés que leur
rémunération abonde Les fonds
spéculatifs et quand on regarde qu'elle
a été la responsabilité des fonds
spéculatifs en question dans l'inflation
ces derniers temps parce que la guerre
en Ukraine est un facteur d'inflation
mais il y en a un autre c'est la
spéculation sur les matières premières
alimentaires clairement
identifié de tous les grands fonds de
pension donc ce n'est pas l'intérêt des
salariés que de d'alimenter un marché
financiarisé fondé sur la spéculation
avec leur propre rémunération c'est pour
ça que je reviendrai te donner sur les
questions démographiques mais il faut
que chacun assume ses positions en fait
c'est pas du système de retraite par
répartition que vous voudriez sauver par
la capitalisation je passe sur le
paradoxe de cette démonstration c'est
vous voulez de l'argent pour la
spéculation
je
veux pas vous priver mais je veux pas
vous forcer non plus
merci Monsieur Merci monsieur le
Président non effectivement nous sommes
pas d'accord pour cette retraite par
capitalisation et effectivement ce sont
deux projets de société qui s'affrontent
la pérennité de notre système de
retraite cela vient d'être dit n'est pas
en danger le corps l'a dit est répété et
donc le problème n'est pas celui de des
dépenses qui devrait évoluer de façon
mauvaise allez je dire mais c'est celui
des recettes
vous avez élevé comme dogme depuis cinq
ans le fait de ne pas augmenter les
recettes et au contraire même des
diminuer vous avez diminué le nombre de
fonctionnaires donc diminuer recettes
vous avez surtout
une nuit de 16 que de d'augmenter les
exonérations sociales mais sont de 85
milliards depuis 2017 les recettes de la
sécurité sociale et en même temps bien
sûr vous diminuez les impôts et les
taxes sur les privilégiés vous montrez
là votre volonté effectivement de donner
aux banques et aux assurances privées
donc à ces fameux formons de pension des
masses énormes d'argent pour pouvoir
spéculer et je voulais redire moi aussi
madame la rapporteur bien sûr que la
jeunesse réfléchit à cette question bien
sûr ça vient d'être dit par Laurence
Rossignol on n'a pas arrêté
de le répéter qui nous rendent droit
aucune retraite que la retraite par
répartition est en danger alors ils sont
inquiets et avec raison ils pensent
qu'ils vont être obligés de continuer à
faire des économies personnelles et de
faire de la capitalisation parce qu'on
n'a pas arrêté de le répéter alors
donnons leur confiance le système pas
répartition et viable ça a été prouvé
par le corps arrêtons de leur faire peur
madame Monnier
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je crois
qu'on leur a fait peur qui sont inquiets
mais que surtout ils savent qu'ils ne
pourront pas le faire parce qu'ils
n'auront pas le moyen de capitaliser
donc mon explication de votre porte sur
la main de manque 4735 et je soutiens
bien sûr la demande portée par ma
collègue Monique Lubin et mes autres
collègues visant à susamender
l'amendement 1968 de Monsieur Husson
afin de supprimer toute référence à la
capitalisation et je crois qu'il faut
être très ferme sur le sujet une telle
mention est un cheval de Troie qui
reviendrait en réalité à acter la fin de
notre système actuel par répartition à
rebours d'ailleurs de la ligne que vous
prétendez défendre monsieur le ministre
la période récente et les crises
boursières qui l'ont ponctué à souligner
à de nombreuses reprises les
incertitudes liées au marché financier
il apparaît donc pour le moins paradoxal
de vouloir sécuriser l'avenir de notre
système actuel de retraite en le faisant
évoluer vers un système mixte la
capitalisation qui confirait une partie
de la retraite des Françaises et des
Français aux aléas des fonds de pension
et des fonds d'investissement par
ailleurs qu'on a eu l'occasion de le
souligner entre autres l'économiste
Thomas picetti le financement des
retraites par capitalisation présente
notre risque celui de l'aggravation des
inégalités entre les Françaises et les
Français au plus haut revenus déjà
détenteurs de capital dans la
capitalisation viendrait soutenir
augmenter les placements investissements
déjà en cours et les autres qui
partiraient avec un temps de retard dans
cette fructification au fond tout
simplement il suffit de parler avec les
citoyens et citoyens pour savoir qu'ils
ont comme je l'ai dit en début du mal à
boucler les fins de mois comment
voulez-vous qu'en plus il puisse
capitaliser pour leur retraite monsieur
Milon et ensuite monsieur Retailleau
merci monsieur le Président je me suis
président monsieur le ministre je
voudrais d'abord remercier René Paul
Savary puisque ce qu'il a dit c'est en
fait le fruit d'une réflexion que nous
avons depuis quelques années entre lui
Catherine de roche les membres de la
commission d'affaires sociales du côté
LR et nous travaillons ce qui veut dire
que nous avons travaillé pour répondre à
ceux qui nous reprochent de ne pas
travailler et nous ne travaillons pas en
catimini pour ceux qui nous reprochent
travailler en catholique mais entre nous
comme vous vous travaillez entre vous
cela dit pourquoi demander un rapport
pourquoi demander un rapport au
gouvernement quand on sait que 16%
simplement des rapports demandés sont
finalement donnés par celui-ci c'est le
premier point et donc si on nous demande
quand même un rapport si nous assistons
jusqu'au bout nous risquons d'avoir un
rapport qui va être donné par un bureau
d'études plutôt que par le gouvernement
lui-même donc pourquoi ne pas le faire
nous-même dans le cas de la commission
des finances et puis la commission
d'affaires sociales en faisant en sorte
que ce soit évidemment des fonds de
capitalisation à la française
c'est-à-dire complémentaire ou
supplémentaire de et puis je voudrais
aussi parler d'un capitalisation
pourquoi être contre la capitalisation
alors que comme l'a dit Madame Lindman
l'effondre réserve qui ont été créés par
Léona Vespa travail par capitalisation
et pourquoi maintenant aussi être contre
les fonds de 4 pièces alors qu'on se
rend compte qu'actuellement les cabinets
médicaux en particulier les centres de
santé les cliniques MCO ou les cliniques
psychiatriques sont rachetées par des
fonds de capitalisation mais étrangers
alors faisons en sorte d'avoir nos
propres fonds de capitalisation à la
française pour pouvoir mieux contrôler
par exemple notre santé président
Retailleau
Monsieur Le Rue du liesse prépare et
ensuite le président Kader oui je
m'étonne si pour la gauche la
capitalisation c'est l'abomination des
abominations alors pourquoi chers
collègues vous n'avez pas déposé des
amendements de suppression pour les deux
régimes individuels et collectifs de
capitalisation pour la fonction publique
nous croyons nous en la retraite par la
répartition parce qu'elle assure un lien
générationnel et c'est parce que nous
voulons sauver cette retraite par
répartition que nous voulons voter après
l'avoir modifié cette réforme
simplement certes cher Pierre ou
juliasses on peut pas prévoir l'économie
de demain mais on peut prévoir la
démographie et on sait très très bien
car j'achèterait partie d'un paraît
partition c'est un régime où la clé
c'est la démographie donc nous voulons
simplement réfléchir étudier et je pense
qu'on pourrait étudier un système d'une
fusée à trois étages le premier étage
c'est le socle c'est la répartition
c'est le lien intergénérationnel le
second étage le deuxième étage c'est les
complémentaires gérés par les
partenaires sociaux c'est d'ailleurs la
retraite un point ou en cotise en partie
pour sa propre attaque en partie et
l'autre étage de la fusée ce serait un
étage par capitalisation la
capitalisation certes pose deux
problèmes le problème c'est que ce doit
être une capitalisation collective
ou en deux disent pas les riches
pourront faire les modestes pourront pas
faire donc il faut un système collectif
et solidaire le deuxième point c'est la
transition c'est la raison pour laquelle
on demande à réfléchir à ce système de
demain c'est absolument fondamental et
par ailleurs par ailleurs si comme vous
comme nous nous sommes attachés à ce que
demain en France il puisse y avoir des
fonds souverains pour que nos centres de
décision ne partent pas si nous voulons
demain en France que nous ayons de
l'argent des Français pour qu'on puisse
investir précisément dans la transition
énergétique la transition écologique il
y aura pas d'autres moyens c'est la
souveraineté financière c'est la
souveraineté industrielle c'est là
qu'elle enjeu et on peut le faire sans
détricoter notre système Monsieur Le Rue
du lieu
merci monsieur le Président alors je
vais retirer mon amendement c'était un
amendement d'appel et je vais manger à
celui de Monsieur Husson mais je
voudrais quand même rassurer la partie
gauche de l'hémicine puisque quand on
sait un peu de recherche sur le système
de retraite il faut savoir que notre
premier système de retraite c'est
1909-1910
c'était Jean Jaurès qui l'a porté qu'il
l'a défendu au nom du réformisme et vous
savez quoi c'était un système de
capitalisation
solidaire et obligatoire pour les petits
salariés les ouvriers et les paysans qui
gagnaient moins de 3000 francs annuels
en 1910 vous voyez comme quoi la cape
est la capitalisation mesdames et
messieurs n'est pas un gros mot merci
monsieur le Président kaner
[Musique]
monsieur
ministre mes chers collègues tout
d'abord sur la forge me félicite que le
rapport que le rapporteur général et
monsieur le rapporteur est estimé que
une demande de rapport ne devait pas
pouvoir être acté par notre assemblée
tout autre décision ont été quand même
curieuses par rapport à tous les
rapports qui ont été entre guillemets
rotoqués et demandés par la gauche de la
Haute Assemblée premièrement et je vous
en remercie deuxièmement
ça y est effectivement nous sommes dans
le clivage droit de gauche évoqué par
Monsieur Retailleau qui n'a pas de
bâillon je tiens à le dire
et Monsieur routaillod si j'étais
facétieux si vous avez lu Le Parisien ce
matin et son titre
je sais donc maintenant que vous ne
voterez pas cette réforme puisqu'elle
est gauche
ça nous avait un peu échappé ça nous
avait un peu échappé qu'elle soit de
gauche mais mais je pense que le
ministre a beaucoup d'humour en la
matière
plus sérieusement sur l'amendement le
rudié même s'il est retiré j'ai envie de
dire c'est quand même un signe fort vous
ne demandez pas dans votre amendement un
simple diagnostic mon cher collègue vous
tenez la main du gouvernement puisque
vous précisez la manière dont mettre en
œuvre cette retraite par capitalisation
et la grande différence finalement c'est
ça qui nous oppose c'est qu'il existe
des systèmes de capitalisation
aujourd'hui dans notre pays on a évoqué
la fonction publique mais aussi la
création dans la loi pacte du PER qui
fonctionne bien d'ailleurs mais là nous
sommes basés sur le volontariat sur la
capacité finalement pour quelqu'un à
dire voilà je complète ma répartition je
complète ma répartition comme je
l'entends parce que dans votre système
monsieur le rue dullier ça signifierait
très concrètement quoi ça signifierait
que la capitalisation est bien viendrait
en substitution progressive de la
répartition et que pour un salarié
modeste il devrait faire des choix en la
matière et bien je le regrette pour nous
c'est non la capitalisation généralisée
se prépare
merci monsieur
convoquer les jeunes j'ai un autre
sondage c'est que 66 % des jeunes sont
des sont favorables à l'augmentation des
cotisations contre l'allongement de la
durée de travail j'espère que vous en
tiendrez donc compte moi je voudrais
quand même rappeler qu'il y a deux
caractéristiques aussi au régime de
répartition qui je crois gène la droite
tout d'abord le régime par répartition
qui est qui était jusqu'à ce jour le
meilleur le plus généreux est un régime
redistributif insuffisamment
redistributif mais redistributif la
deuxième chose deuxième caractéristique
qui est absolument anthonyme de du
régime à capitalisation c'est que notre
régime est en partie pour le régime
général après station définie
c'est-à-dire sur les 25 années vous
allez cotiser et la moitié du plafond
etc etc
et c'est pour les Français cette partie
à prestation définie et non le marché
dans 30 ans ce qui est ce que lui
donnera le marché représente de 40 à 70%
selon les catégories
socioprofessionnelles donc je pense
qu'effectivement tant le côté
redistributif insuffisamment mais quand
même inscrit dans le régime de
répartition qui éradiqué la pauvreté
chez les personnes âgées que le système
prestation définie cela ne vous sied pas
la deuxième chose que je dirais c'est
qu'il faut pas mélanger les réserves je
suis désolé les réserves ne qualit pas
une qualifie pas le régime de
capitalisation ça a rien à voir c'est
une gestion à long terme un lissage du
régime par répartition donc c'est pas le
fait de placer qui fait cela la
troisième chose vite que je dirais c'est
que les rendements que vous qui sont
demandés en général par le
concurrisation donc je conclus ce font
contre les travailleurs quand ils
demandent des plans de licenciement ou
se font dans ce qui rapporte le plus les
industries extractives les industries
fossiles monsieur Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues d'abord une remarque si la
retraite par répartition est la première
étage d'une fusée quand on lance une
fusée on lâche le premier étage pour que
la fusée continue et donc j'avoue que
c'est assez inquiétant la deuxième
remarque pour dire merci enfin vrai
débat enfin un vrai débat et merci aussi
au rapporteurs Russon dont je connais
l'exigence constante vis-à-vis du
gouvernement de souligner à quel point
nous sommes dans une situation qui
empêche ce vrai débat parce que nous ne
sommes pas en train de parler d'une loi
de rectification de la sécurité sociale
avec ce débat chers collègues nous
sommes en train d'ouvrir un débat sur
les traîtres comme on devrait l'avoir
par une loi ordinaire malheureusement le
temps contraint puisque c'est à travers
d'amendement ne nous permettra pas de le
faire alors je voudrais dire une chose
sur la démographie on pourrait avoir une
bonne demi-heure de discussion très
tranquillement parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de variables sur le partage de la valeur
produite qui évoquait Fabien gay c'est
quand même un sujet qui mérite d'être
évoqué et qui l'est jamais sur les bancs
de la droite maintenant je voudrais dire
un mot sur notre contexte
de mondialisation libérale et de
financiarisation la capitalisation a
construit des acteurs financiers privés
plus puissant que les États
Blackrock en est l'illustration maximale
et le paradoxe c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
veuve du Michigan où le boulanger de
l'Ohio finance des projets qui les
mettent eux-mêmes à genoux et finance
d'abord des projets climaticides
effectivement parce que ce sont
aujourd'hui les plus rentables ils
financent ensuite des projets
d'aggravation des inégalités qui vont
jusque et notre collègue la présidente
Rossignol l'a évoqué jusqu'à affamer des
pays en spéculant sur la nourriture et
sur l'alimentation alors il y a un vrai
problème de ce côté là parce que la
financiarisation et les grands groupes
privés n'ont jamais été un outil de
progrès donc il faut chercher d'autres
conclure le fond de réserve des
retraites est une de ces réponses madame
de La Gontrie
et Madame Lubin ensuite
merci monsieur le Président explication
de vote sur le sous amendement 47 35
alors effectivement on assiste
aujourd'hui à droite et avec le
gouvernement évidemment un retour en
arrière historique pourquoi ça a été
évoqué tout à l'heure effectivement les
retraites par capitalisation ont été
monsieur le Rudy il a rappelé instaurer
début du siècle c'était assez nouveau
sauf que
on a constaté que très vite une part
importante des travailleurs français
n'avaient pas de quoi faire face à ce
système par capitalisation il y a eu la
loi 1910 vous l'avez évoqué très
rapidement Monsieur Le Rue dulier les
retraites ouvrières et paysannes la CGT
s'y était opposée parce que l'âge
d'application était tellement tardive
qu'il a appelé la CGT appelé cette loi
la retraite des morts mais en tout état
de cause elle était financée par
plusieurs intervenants dont l'État et
puis 36 plusieurs d'évaluations
effondrement des ressources et
instauration de la retraite par
répartition en 1945 et c'est là que j'en
viens parce que je crois que à droite
ici les gaullistes que je croyais que
vous étiez où vous êtes peut-être
post-gauliste devrait y être attentif
aujourd'hui vous faites le chemin
exactement inverse fusée à deux étages
vous diminuez les droits vous diminuez
les droits donc évidemment c'est un
scoop de constater que les jeunes sont
inquiets tous les jours ils entendent
qu'ils n'auront plus de retraite et de
ce fait les droits étant diminués vous
alimentez l'idée qu'il vaut mieux
économiser pour soi-même pour demain
parce que de toute façon il n'y aura pas
de retraite alors madame Doisneau oui
l'inquiétude croit elle a cru de 3% rien
qu'en 2023 tout de même des personnes
inquiète et du coup j'interrogerai le
ministre il a dit tout à l'heure que
c'était une interprétation personnelle
et que je partage d'une inquiétude pour
les petits les personnes les plus
modestes est-ce que cet adjectif de
personnel tente à indiquer que ce n'est
pas le cas du reste du gouvernement qui
ne se préoccup e pas de cette situation
oui monsieur le Président mon
explication de vote porte sur l'article
174 vous avez dit Monsieur Le Rue
dullier vous avez commencé votre
raisonnement en parlant de la
démographie bien évidemment en matière
de retraite comme sur d'autres sujets
d'ailleurs on entend beaucoup de
ponctifs et de choses qui si on ne va
pas se documenter paraissent d'une
évidence absolue la démographie alors la
démographie comme l'a dit mon collègue
Fabien gay il y a un bon moment quelle
est qu'elle baisse n'est-ce pas et nous
avons eu à affronter et je dis bien eu
parce que le mouvement est quasiment sur
sa fin le fameux papy boom et les
rapports du corps sont très clairs
là-dessus le papy boom nous l'avons
absorbé grâce justement aux gaines de
productivité donc il faut arrêter de
dire que le pire est absolument devant
nous parce que jusqu'à maintenant
justement nous avons une autre économie
à directement réussi à endosser ces
choses-là ensuite vous vous avez rappelé
comment était né le premier système de
retraite moi je vais vous dire autre
chose effectivement premier système de
retraite ont été basés en partie sur la
capitalisation mais la crise de
1929 et l'hyperinflation entre les deux
guerres ont altéré la rentabilité des
placements financiers et provoquer une
très lourde dépréciation des pensions et
comme le précise l'économiste Philippe
trenard entre 1914 et 1939 les prix vont
augmenter de 600% au total divisant par
7 le pouvoir d'achat des rentes sur la
période c'est alors que l'État français
s'est tourné vers l'assurance publique
et le système par répartition indexé sur
les salaires et l'inflation et les
fondements du système par répartition
sont donc liés à une peur de
l'incertitude financière renforcée par
les crises boursières récentes depuis
les années 2000 le gong je pense que
vous avez
expliqué votre vote sur l'abandon de
Monsieur Husson celui de Monsieur Lorie
dulier ayant été retiré voilà
monsieur le Président Laurent puis
monsieur Aido puis le président rénal
oui deux petites remarques d'abord la
première c'est que tous les rapports ne
sont pas traités à la même enseigne par
les rapporteurs je l'avais posé la
question vous m'avez répondu le
contraire je le note c'est pas très
correct
deuxièmement effectivement c'est bien
que la droite mette son projet de
société sur la table qui est
effectivement un projet contrôle le
système par répartition et je note que
c'est le projet de toutes les droites
parce que dans les deux amendements qui
nous sont présentés il y a tout le monde
il y a même je le note au passage
puisque personne ne l'a remarqué il y a
même monsieur ravier qui est signataire
dans des deux amendements c'est
intéressant à noter
alors moi je veux répondre sur une chose
parce que dans votre argumentation vous
commencez par dire comme si c'était une
évidence non discutable
il nous allons vers
le
l'épuisement idéal du système par
répartition à cause de la démographie et
bien c'est faux c'est faux d'abord parce
que il y a déjà eu des évolutions
démographiques elles ont été absorbées
par le système par répartition grâce au
progrès de la productivité et des
évolutions déjà très importantes
deuxièmement le corps dit exactement le
contraire le corps dit que pour les
décennies à venir il n'y a pas de
problème de financement massif avec la
répartition et troisièmement si on parle
de la question démographique dans le
rapport actif retraité il faut pas
seulement parler du nombre il faut
parler de la qualité du rapport
le niveau des salaires pourquoi alors
que moins d'actifs financent l'ensemble
du régime les salaires ne sont pas plus
élevés parce que ça ferait augmenter les
recettes pourquoi nous n'allons pas plus
vite sur l'égalité salariale femme homme
pourquoi nous ne travaillons pas
davantage la qualité de l'emploi donc si
nous avons des politiques d'emplois
vertueuses et bien ce sera vertueux pour
que le système donc oui le système par
répartition à de l'avenir et la question
démographique n'est pas le problème
monsieur Olivier nos
puis monsieur Reynal depuis madame
président monsieur le ministre une
première remarque j'avais déjà envie de
la faire hier soir on nous a beaucoup
reproché notre silence
alors moi mes chers collègues je
respecte totalement la flibusterie
complet parlementaire je peux même la
comprendre mais de là à nous reprocher
notre silence je trouve parfois que vous
abusez je vous remercie d'abord de
prendre cette remarque la deuxième
observation concerne ce débat bien
évidemment c'est une demande de rapport
donc notre tradition veut qu'on le
refuse mais première observation
la cette question est un débat
intéressant si il s'agissait de demander
de substituer à la répartition la
capitalisation je serai contre et donc
pas de caricature nous sommes contre en
revanche aborder cette question s'int
dans un débat comme celui-ci ça
m'apparaît tout à fait indispensable
bien évidemment il est important que la
question de la démographie on peut pas
regarder la répartition quand il y a
cinq actifs pour un pour retraité comme
si comme comme demain il va en avoir 1,5
pour 1 ce serait ça manquerait de
lucidité de pas regarder les choses et
en même temps sur la capitalisation vous
savez c'est un peu comme Monsieur
Jourdain on en fait la capitalisation
c'est comme la prose et combien ici ont
des assurances vie combien ici regarde
parfois les fonds communs de placement
donc
refusé d'aborder cette question de la
capitalisation c'est au fond privé les
plus modestes de la capitalisation
voilà les sénateurs sont en train
d'enchaîner les explications de vote et
contrairement à hier et bien on entend
les voix de la droite clairement
s'exprimer sur la retraite par
capitalisation vous l'avez vu il y a
deux amendements de la droite un signe
de Stéphane lereux dullier et puis un
autre notamment que signé par Bruneaux
Retailleau pour demander et bien à
réfléchir à un rapport pour voir comment
coupler et bien un système de retraite
par capitalisation c'est-à-dire où les
actifs épargnent en vue de leur propre
retraite future et mise souvent sur des
fonds de pension avec notre système
actuel par répartition où ce sont les
actifs d'aujourd'hui qui financent les
retraites des retraités actuels écoutez
et bien à ce propos l'intervention de
Bruno Retailleau le président du groupe
alerte tout à l'heure dans l'hémicycle
si comme vous comme nous nous sommes
attachés à ce que demain en France il
puisse y avoir des fonds souverains pour
que nos centres de décision ne partent
pas si nous voulons demain en France que
nous ayons de l'argent des Français pour
qu'on puisse investir précisément dans
la transition énergétique la transition
écologique il y aura pas d'autres moyens
c'est la souveraineté financière c'est
la souveraineté industrielle c'est là
qui est l'enjeu et on peut le faire sans
détricoter notre système
et cela a été aussi l'occasion
d'entendre un autre président de groupe
le président du groupe socialiste
Patrick canard qui a profité de son
intervention et bien pour taquiner pour
tacler Bruno retaillod notamment et bien
par rapport à l'interview qui a été
donné dans le Parisien Aujourd'hui par
le ministre du Travail Olivier du socle
qui dit et bien que la réforme des
retraites est de gauche il y a donc dit
à Bruno Retailleau qu'il ne devrait donc
pas logiquement voter cette réforme il
s'est aussi réjouit qu'il y ait enfin et
bien un véritable débat dans l'hémicycle
ce matin et à réaffirmé bien
l'opposition très claire de la gauche au
fait et bien d'aller vers une retraite
par capitalisation écoutée Patrick
canard
Ier ça signifierait très concrètement
quoi ça signifie que la capitalisation
est bien viendrait en substitution
progressive de la répartition et que
pour un salarié modeste il devrait faire
des choix en la matière et bien je le
regrette pour nous c'est non la
capitalisation généralisée voilà c'est
non la capitalisation
généralisée a dit Patrick canard
néanmoins et bien écoutez notez que
c'est le moment en fin d'un vrai débat
de fond dans ce moment de discussion
dans l'hémicycle et dans tout le monde
s'est réjouit et bien les explications
de vote a continué à s'égrainer on va
maintenant voir revenir et bien dans
l'hémicycle en haut j'ai un archer
continue de présider la séance
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues alors je ne
veux absolument pas être désagréable je
fais juste le constat et je me réjouis
que vous ayez retrouvé la parole
aujourd'hui car véritablement nous
sommes dans l'un dans l'exercice de la
démocratie au sein du Sénat comme nous
les monts nous confrontons nos points de
vue nous ne sommes pas d'accord on le
voit mais voilà nous sommes là vraiment
dans le respect des points de vue des
uns et des autres et je me réjouis de de
cette situation mais aussi dire que ça a
été dit précédemment et là je sais que
ça va réagir dire que enfin les masques
tombent car vous dites que vous soutenez
et que vous voulez préserver le système
par répartition mais en même temps vous
faites aussi cet amendement vous
proposez cet amendement pour d'une
certaine façon certes demander un
rapport mais finalement
promouvoir le système par capitalisation
je veux répondre aussi à un de nos
collègues qui a évoqué le système
suédois qui est cité en exemple
je pense qu'on peut aussi avoir des
similitudes chez nous et au rendement
médiocre de certains fonds de pension et
bien contribue à la poupérisation d'une
partie des retraités suédois et en
particulier les femmes seules on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir Monsieur Jacques
merci monsieur le Président j'interviens
sur le 1968 monsieur le ministre je ne
sais pourquoi le débat est devenu d'une
telle qualité peut-être sous l'effet de
votre président ou sous l'effet d'une
inspiration dominicale je ne sais pas
mais il devient vraiment passionnant et
les masques tombent et
j'apprécie de plus en plus ce débat
itératif qui nous permet d'approfondir
les arguments et pour ma part cette nuit
j'ai eu un rêve
si vous imaginez des corps de livreurs à
vélo de 64 ans 65 ans vous livrez des
plats froids à petite vitesse mais oui
je travaille beaucoup sur la question
des travailleurs de plateformes et je
voulais évoquer sans plaisanter ce matin
la sous-déclaration dans le régime des
auto-entrepreneurs qui est quasiment sur
la base du volontariat j'ai eu quelques
mois un rendez-vous avec l'excellent
directeur de Lacoste qui m'a appris le
l'estimation par Lacosse de cette
sous-déclaration dans le régime des
Antos entrepreneurs la connaissez-vous
que ce soit l'omission les oublis les
erreurs et qui sait peut-être la fraude
je ne sais pas
non pas la fraude
alors Monsieur le Ministre et monsieur
le rapporteur qui avait eu accès aux
rapports du Conseil d'État vous ne
pouvez pas répondre mais je crois que je
n'ai pas le droit d'interpeller mes
collègues donc je vais donner la réponse
c'est plus de 60% des cotisations qui ne
sont pas versées et c'est pas une
estimation c'est un travail approfondie
de de Lacosse et donc je suis très
inquiet si votre rêve qui apparaît ce
matin de résine de capitalisation venait
à exister sur la base du volontariat je
serais vraiment très très inquiet en
conclusion retirer cette réforme et cet
amendement je vous remercie monsieur le
questeur bas
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
ne nous faisons pas de procès
d'intention tout le débat que nous avons
pour une seule chose c'est qu'on a
besoin d'avoir un débat serein sur cette
notion de capitalisation parce qu'on a
un peu tendance à lui prêter des
conséquences ou une portée qu'elle n'a
pas nécessairement après tout puisque
nous ne sommes pas d'accord sur ce que
apporterait la capitalisation à notre
régime pas répartition éclaireau le
débat par des études impartiales que
nous pourrons ensuite discuter ensemble
moi ce que je voudrais vous dire c'est
que les Français ne nous ont pas attendu
1876 milliards de placements en
assurance vie
57% des Français propriétaires de leur
logement
croyez pas ne sois pas destiné avant
tout alors qu'il y a une certaine
inquiétude sur l'avenir de la
rapartition à consolider les moyens de
nos compatriotes quand ils vont prendre
de l'âge la capitalisation ils
connaissent ils pratiquent sauf ceux qui
n'ont pas les moyens d'épargner
et par conséquent alors que nos régimes
para répartition que nous nous efforçons
de consolider sans beaucoup d'aide de
votre part chers collègues qui siégé sur
les bancs de la gauche
non pas aujourd'hui
l'avenir assuré sans réforme importante
il est important de se dire que
amener du provisionnement serait une
manière de rétablir aussi la confiance
dans la répartition ce provisionnement
d'ailleurs nous en avons la pratique le
premier à l'avoir imaginé ce Monsieur
Lionel jaspin dernière fait d’autres
polaires qu'un fonds de réserve des
retraites 26 milliards de capitaux
placés aujourd'hui agir Carco 86
milliards de capitaux placés Caisse
nationale des processions libérales 34
milliards tout 180 milliards de capitaux
placés ils sont pas sur un compte du
Trésor public ils sont en obligation et
en action ils sont gérés alors mes chers
collègues n'ayons pas peur de réfléchir
et simplement de réfléchir en toute
bonne foi à l'apport possible de la
capitalisation pour renforcer la
répartition
monsieur moto G
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président cher
collègue monsieur le ministre pour les
Français qui nous écoutent
mettons les choses en perspective
politique en réalité une réforme en
cache une autre dans les intentions du
gouvernement et de la majorité
sénatorielle qui le soutient j'y vois la
démonstration de votre volonté
insidieuse d'utiliser la réforme
initiale pour installer les conditions
d'une migration progressive vers un
système par capitalisation qui monterait
en puissance dans les années à venir
plus de cette Français sur 10 rejette
votre réforme paramétrique fondée sur
les 64 ans et les 43 ennuités ils seront
plus résolus encore et plus nombreux à
rejeter la seconde réforme caché
celle-là qui est introduite par ces
demandes de rapport y compris par le
gouvernement donc les explications de
vote se multiplier plaisir d'accueillir
le président du groupe des sénateurs RDP
un dessinateur Renaissance ici au Sénat
François Patriat bonjour
François Patriat on a entendu des voix
qui se réjouissaient ce matin qu'il y
ait enfin un débat un débat autour et
bien de l'introduction d'une part de
capitalisation dans notre système que
aujourd'hui un système par répartition
est-ce que vous y êtes personnellement
favorable je ne suis pas favorable je
suis
dans cette hémicycle en soutien de la
loi que propose le gouvernement qui vise
à protéger et amplifier la répartition
et référence en sorte que la solidarité
internationale générationnelle se
poursuivent la retraite par
capitalisation on sait ce que ça donne
dans d'autres pays on a vu ce que
peuvent apporter les fonds aléatoire par
ailleurs je pense que je sais très bien
que la retraite par capitalisation c'est
l'affaire de ceux qui peuvent la payer
pareil je prends aujourd'hui que notre
système est exemplaire il est envié il
est le meilleur aujourd'hui il est celui
de la répartition reste bien entendu que
ceux qui veulent ou qui peuvent faire de
la capitalisation à côté peuvent le
faire personne ne les empêche dans la
loi mais il n'est pas question de venir
à une forme de capitalisation
blocage on a vu des amendements à
répétition hier à la virgule près par
dizaines par centaines on voit ce matin
que en 1h30 près de deux heures on aura
fait deux amendements parce qu'il y a
des explications de votre redondante le
comique de répétition assez limite je
peux les supporter je suis là c'est cool
je suis là en soutien du gouvernement
j'espère qu'on pourra avancer un peu
parce que je crois que tout a été dit
sur cette réforme aujourd'hui il y
aurait un seul orateur dans chaque camp
pour expliquer on gagnerait du temps
parce que les répétitions ne sont pas là
pour éclairer le débat vous vous agacez
du rythme actuel vous demandez justement
à ce que et bien on prenne un autre
rythme et que on limite les orateurs sur
les prises de parole il y a un certain
nombre de possibilités dans les
règlements du Sénat notamment l'article
38 dont on a déjà beaucoup parlé vous
appelez à ce qu'il soit dégainé pour
pouvoir aller plus vite et aboutir à un
vote dimanche je crois que c'est le
responsabilité de la présidence du Sénat
si le président il l'a dit et je lui
enseigné qu'il souhaitait que
quel est le rôle du Parlement le rôle du
Parlement c'est bientôt tenu de débattre
le débat doit éclairer une décision
faut-il encore que cette décision soit
prise si on dépasse dans le vide pendant
des heures et des heures des jours et
des nuits
c'est l'opposition c'est ce que fait la
gauche aujourd'hui manifestement vous
avez vu les amendements de 50 qui
passeraient de 2050 49 39 et tout hier
déposé comme ça 30 amendements avec 30
explications de vote et surtout moi ici
je pense que le règlement du Sénat n'est
plus adapté qu'on est comme ça vient ça
se passe actuellement j'ai quitté
l'hémicycle parce que j'étais un peu
énervé de voir qu'on en était à la 30e
explication de vote sur un
sous-amendement
je crois qu'on peut faire mieux et que
les Français comprendraient mieux alors
un point majeur du texte a été adopté
hier un fois François Patriat malgré
cette obstruction de la coach celui qui
prévoit la fin de certains régimes
spéciaux pour les nouveaux entrants les
électriciens les gaziers la Banque de
France mais le match il va continuer à
se jouer dans l'hémicycle sur ce sujet
la droite veut que cela puisse concerner
et bien beaucoup plus largement n'ont
pas les nouveaux entrants mais ceux qui
sont déjà en train de travailler dans
ces secteurs quand vous l'avoir déjà dit
dans une émission la semaine dernière
je suis favorable à ce qu'on maintienne
la clause du grand-père ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire la cause de la parole
donnée les gens qui sont entrés qui ont
accepté qui ont postulé pour un emploi
dans des conditions bien déterminées
avec des avantages des inconvénients les
salaires peut-être pas très élevé mais
la retraite ceux qui l'ont signé dans
ces conditions doit pouvoir le garder
jusqu'au bout donc moi je pense qu'on
aura sans doute ce débat demain
très bien que la droite durcir le texte
par ailleurs en disant qu'elles occupent
des plus faibles elle veut le durcir je
crois qu'il y a une question là de
justice de parole donnée moi je suis
pour le maintien de la clause du
grand-père on l'a déjà fait pour la SNCF
la loi que nous allons voter doit
concerner les futurs entrants elle ne
peut pas concerner les océans sauf je
retourne en l'occurrence pour le minimum
contributif une toute dernière question
sur un point que l'on dont on attend la
discussion aujourd'hui l'article 2
article qui porte sur l'index seniors la
droite sénatoriale veut instaurer un CDI
senior avec une exonération de
cotisation famille pour ce type de
contrat il êtes-vous favorable moi je
voudrais qu'on connaisse le coup
aujourd'hui d'abord l'index seniors il
est c'est une avancée par rapport à ce
qui existait avant et je pense que sur
le travail des seniors nous avons encore
du chemin à parcourir je pense qu'on
peut encore avancer et sur le CDI j'ai
pas le chiffre en tête mais je crois que
ça coûte plusieurs dizaines de
multiplie vous le soulignez tout à
l'heure François Patriat sur ses
amendements autour et bien de
l'ouverture vers une retraite par
capitalisation
la confiance
le sénateur communiste qui est en train
de faire son explication de vote les
jeunes dans la capitalisation quand le
ministre monsieur bichu leur dire que la
température moyenne de la France sera
plus 5 degrés nous n'avons aucune aucune
visibilité sur ce que sera notre climat
notre industrie dans 20 ans voire même
10 ans là la question des retraites est
complètement liée à la question
climatique et vous ne l'abordez pas
voilà et aujourd'hui la seule garantie
pour justement s'assurer qu'il puisse y
encore avoir des retraites à tout le
monde avec une température moyenne qui
va augmenter de 100 degrés c'est bien
encore une fois la répartition merci
monsieur le président
alors Monsieur ça va le débit merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mais chers collègues c'est vrai
qu'on a des séances différentes on était
dans le silence
avec quand même des sous-entendus de
mensonges politiques et aujourd'hui
la noblesse du débat arrive puisque
maintenant la parole est d'argent ah oui
parce que c'est le sujet et moi je
trouve que les choses sont intéressantes
et un peu plus passionnantes puisque le
président Retailleau est parole d'argent
ce matin et à l'image de l'amendement de
notre collègue Husson mais aussi de
l'uruguier c'est quoi vous souhaitez
introduire des fonds de pension
souverain public
vous voyez qu'on écoute
bah alors il va falloir individuel
individualiser les droits
et là il faut faire attention parce
qu'il y a un loup sous tout ça alors moi
je suis pas un champion des éléments de
langage j'ai pas de communiquant qui
m'aide j'ai mon expérience politique
militante vous parlez de capitalisation
solidaire on devait quand les versements
ça paraissant franchement capitalisation
solidaire on se dit merde c'est des
valeurs de droite de gauche allez c'est
nos valeurs à tous hop pas un mot sur la
redistribution et là on détourne le
problème on arrive à démographie pour
dire bah tiens on va oublier la valeur
ajoutée bah tiens bah évidemment mais
parce que là on est sur le rapport
gauche-droite on est on est dans des
camps et des intérêts différents et ça
s'appelle tout simplement la ligne de
classe chacun défend les intérêts qui
lui semblent supérieur aux autres parce
que qu'est-ce que vous allez oublier
qu'est-ce qu'il a oublié le président
Retailleau et notre collègue ils sont
dans son amendement mais c'est bien les
riches parce que les deux années de ce
qu'on va demander au travailleur de
faire on va leur dire quand ils vont le
faire pour la solidarité donc ça va être
au détriment de qui on va construire
cette solidarité nouvelle au détriment
d'un seul camp de celle et ceux qui
travaillent les autres épargner
totalement et c'est pas un hasard si
avant d'avoir ce débat ici on a eu à
quelques jours un projet de loi du
collègue Usson et de Mongolfier sur les
épargnants parce que pourquoi parce
qu'ils sont en train de créer un outil
fiscal pour qu'on passe de l'assurance
vie au plan épargne retraite individuel
avec des avantages considérables et vous
savez qui c'est qui c'est qui va être le
principal bénéficiaire c'est ceux qui
sont imposés sur le revenu à 41%. c'est
des gens que les revenus de 80.000 euros
annuels il défileront pas le 7 cela s'il
vous plaît merci
Madame pour ce Pauline
moi je me pose une question depuis tout
à l'heure monsieur le ministre le rôle
d'un président de la République est-il
finalement celui d'être le garant des
fonds de pension nous l'avons compris
vous avez une obsession qui ne vous
quitte pas vous et la droite sénatoriale
nous faire travailler plus longtemps
faire travailler nos enfants plus
longtemps et les pousser à la
capitalisation dans Le Parisien le PDG
de Total d'ailleurs un de vos amis 6
millions d'euros par an prendre la
retraite à 64 ans il n'a pas de mots
assez doux pour prôner cette retraite à
64 ans il vente évidemment à vos côtés
la capitalisation ça va de soi je crois
que là on est vraiment dans un débat de
fond projet par projet et que nous
sommes au cœur de la réforme oui
nous sommes pour la répartition et vous
êtes pour les fonds de pensions et la
capitalisation nous l'avons bien compris
mais est-ce que vous pensez alors j'ai
j'ai entendu caricatures non j'ai
entendu le président ba
57% des Français épargnent
voilà il y en a quand même 43% je lui
fais remarquer qu'il épargne pas donc
voilà et alors est-ce que vous pensez
est-ce que vous pensez est-ce que vous
pensez véritablement que les caissières
les aident à domicile les petits
smicards
non mais vous rigolez pas à sang dans la
capitalisation vous savez où ils sont
actuellement ils se font la queue au
Resto du Coeur ils sont au Secours
populaire ils n'arrivent plus à payer
leur électricité leur gaz ils pensent
tous les jours à se nourrir mais oui
monsieur c'est ça la réalité de l'avion
que toi peut-être pas les mêmes en tous
les cas vous irez dire à tous ces gens
qu'il faut qu'il capitalise parce que
finalement vous voulez leur enlever le
régime par répartition
merci à monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues depuis
le début de nos débats on tente de nous
expliquer que l'effort demandait aux
Français n'a d'autres vu que de sauver
le régime par répartition et maintenant
on nous dit que ce régime ne peut être
sauvé sauf à capitaliser collectivement
proposer un tel système c'est affaiblir
dans un premier temps la retraite par
répartition ça a été démontré avant de
le condamner complètement
ce système par capitalisation serait
nourrir des illusions dans la population
avec des promesses non tenues ma
collègue a évoqué tout à l'heure la
situation des chiliens et il est il est
vrai
parfaitement éclairant difficile de
parler
de capitalisation comment parler
effectivement de solidarité
générationnelle avec des placements et
surtout avec le rendement de ces
placements si la clé d'un régime va
répartition c'est la démographie comme
j'ai pu l'entendre sur les bancs de
droite celle de la capitalisation n'est
en aucune façon la solidarité en fait au
bout du compte nous examinons un texte
qui veut fragiliser une grande partie de
nos concitoyens et comme si cela n'était
pas suffisant on veut le renlever ce
pourquoi en leur demande de contribuer
toujours et en plus et encore plus
longtemps je vous remercie
alors mes chers collègues comment
peut-on parler aujourd'hui de retraite
par capitalisation qui je le rappelle
n'a aucune protection en cas
d'accapacité alors qu'actuellement on
discute également d'aide pour nos
salariés je rappelle qu'on vote des
aides pour l'énergie ou pour le
carburant pour aller travailler mais on
augmente pas significativement les
salaires de ces salariés donc on
pourrait augmenter les cotisations aussi
bien patronales le corps le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites ne prévoit
pas de situation catastrophiques comme
le disait mon collègue Pierre Laurent
dans le pire de des scénarios le déficit
du système de retraite sera compris
entre 0,5 et 0,8 points du PIB d'ici
2032 donc on a le temps de voir venir il
y a pas d'urgence et la démocratie la
démographie est un faux débat par contre
moi j'ai aussi une autre solution parce
qu'on parle toujours des mêmes solutions
les solutions du patronat moi j'ai aussi
la solution qu'on pourrait peut-être
voir un rapport sur le cice qui a aucun
effet sur l'emploi aucun effet sur
investissement aucun effet sur les
commerces extérieures et ça ça nous
rapporte 22 milliards d'euros par an
merci Monsieur Husson vous vouliez
oui monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues quelques éléments simplement
complémentaires par rapport aux éléments
que nous avons déjà évoqué il est
proposé de réfléchir sur un système de
capitalisation obligatoire universelle
je dis bien universel
l'objectif c'est évidemment aussi de
nourrir notre économie française parce
que lorsque les Français investissent
dans leur économie ils garantissent la
souveraineté du pays et notamment un bon
déploiement de l'activité économique au
plus près de nos territoires je vais
également vous dire que un chiffre est
important c'est ce qu'on appelle le taux
de récupération la génération qui est né
en 1940 quand elle cotisait 100 000 elle
récupérait 200 000 celle qui était en 65
quand elle cotisait 100 000 elle
récupérait 160 000 celle des années 90
récupérait 87000 ce sont des éléments
dont vous devez avoir connaissance et
puis le le système de capitalisation
universelle obligatoire il existe avec
les raphs je l'ai mis dans les éléments
que je vous ai communiqué c'est
important parce qu'on a traversé la
crise financière et bien depuis 2005 si
on regarde la CNAV la revalorisation
moyenne annuelle
1,22%. Arco
1,09 le RAF 1 29 même avec un temps de
crise ce que je vais vous dire par là
enfin c'est que la répartition ne
fonctionne pour l'instant qu'avec deux
tiers des cotisations de retraite le
dernier tiers ce sont des impôts ou de
la dette donc le fait de vouloir
réfléchir ensemble c'est mieux que c'est
mieux que de rester de côté et puis je
terminerai par un petit trait d'humour
cet amendement il n'est nullement
soutenu par la Chili cône Valley et au
regard de son numéro je vous propose de
soutenir et d'adopter cet amendement 68
heures
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues moi je
trouve le débat que nous avons ce matin
extrêmement intéressant et on voit bien
l'opposition entre deux projets de
société droit de gauche et Monsieur le
Ministre très fort qu'on a
décrite hier sur les bancs de gauche
comme étant une mauvaise réforme en fait
elle ouvre c'est la réforme des droites
rassemblées on le voit bien elle ouvre
la porte à une réforme par
capitalisation c'est ça la question
quand on porte des coups au système de
un autre système de retraite on
encourage les retraites parallèles avec
des fonds de pension ce qui remet en
cause les fondements même de la sécurité
sociale Régis mettas Salma qui est un
syndicaliste explique je le cite ce
système pousse les salariés à réclamer
des primes plutôt que des hausses de
salaire car ce sont les primes et en
même temps ce sont les primes qui
alimentent l'épargne retraite or vous le
savez mes chers collègues les primes
sont exonérées de cotisations sociales
c'est une façon supplémentaire de
siphonner notre sécurité sociale en
épuisant les recettes de ce système et
cette politique libérale est le fil
rouge de la politique voulue par le
président Macron en 2019 la loi pacte à
libéralisé les dispositifs des plans
d'épargne retraite en fait c'est un
système bien huilé que vous mettez en
place avec cette réforme que l'on
examine aujourd'hui au niveau du Sénat
c'est un système bien humilié pour
renforcer celui de la capitalisation et
la marchandisation des pensions et nous
au niveau des affaires sociales avec ma
collègue Katia pour ce poli on le voit à
longueur d'année cette cette
fragilisation de notre système de
protection sociale de sécurité sociale
en retirant absolument et en
encourageant toutes les exonérations de
cotisations sociales vous épuisez les
recettes de la sécurité sociale pour la
condamner et c'est ce que vous continuez
projet après projet de faire et c'est
mauvais pour l'ensemble des salariés
merci
sur le Président je fais un peu désolé
je vais baisser le temps je vois un
petit peu cassée voilà donc moi je salue
le débat de ce matin qui est
effectivement
contrairement à hier d'un niveau supra
qui est bien plus intéressant
mais je pense qu'un
je pouvais peut-être merci
je vais nous laisser nous exprimer je
pense que ce débat d'ailleurs mérite
mieux que les caricatures que l'on
connaît quand même entendu d'un côté de
l'hémicycle mérite également mieux et
pendant que les explications de votre
continu à se multiplier un tour de cette
amendement LR qui propose de réfléchir à
introduire une part de capitalisation
dans notre système actuel de retraite
pas répartition on va rejoindre Audrey
Audrey jetaz qui est dans l'hémicycle du
Sénat où vous ne manquez rien de toutes
les interventions des sénateurs Audrey
et où notamment vous avez été marqué par
des interventions du côté gauche de
l'hémicycle oui et on assiste à un vrai
débat de société extrêmement
intéressante sur notre système de
retraite un débat avec des prises de
parole qui s'opposent entre la gauche et
les sénateurs de droite les sénateurs de
gauche qui se sont félicités justement
de le débat à plusieurs reprises c'est
vrai que depuis le début de l'examen de
ce projet de loi la droite était restée
plutôt silencieuse là les prises de
parole s'altères entre les sénateurs de
gauche et de droite on parle donc d'une
question d'introduire une dose de
capitalisation dans notre système actuel
ça vient d'une idée de plusieurs
sénateurs LR qui estiment que c'est le
seul moyen de préserver notre système de
retraite système de retraite qui je le
rappelle est en place depuis la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et qui est par
capitalisation ça veut dire que ce sont
les actifs qui payent pour les retraités
ces sénateurs et l'air voudrait qu'on
introduise une dose de capitalisation et
donc le fait d'investir certaines
cotisations en bourse pour la gauche
c'est inaudible et ça a donné lieu à une
très grosse prise de parole de la
sénatrice communiste à poursôt poli
écouté son intervention est-ce que vous
pensez
véritablement que les caissières les
aides à domicile les petits smicards
[Musique]
portera aussi sont opposés à cette
amendement mais plutôt pour une question
de forme car les amendements appellent à
réfléchir à établir un rapport sur le
sujet puisque sur le fond où il trouve
que le sujet de réflexion est
intéressant d'ailleurs écoutez bien René
n'est pas le Savary le rapporteur de la
branche vieillasse qui est en train de
s'exprimer dans les muscles non c'est la
réforme Touraine qui allonge le délai à
43 ans et quand vous commencez à 21 ans
que vous travaillez 43 ans vous
arriverez à 64 ans la réforme proposée
simplement de faire en sorte que en
décalage et bien on n'est pas des
retraités pauvres ça mérite d'être
souligné d'autre part on nous a parlé
d'obsession qu'il y aurait sur certains
bancs de parler de capitaux ce ne sont
pas des obsédés ce sont des sénateurs
qui mènent une réflexion particulière
pour faire en sorte que là aussi nous
n'ayons pas des retraités pauvres
d'autre part certains
je parle du corps du déficit engendré
dans les analyses du corps toutes les
analyses conduites à un déficit virgule
avec un niveau de pension relative des
retraités qui sera à 85 % à l'horizon
2050 quand il est aujourd'hui à 103 %
n'oubliez pas de le dire que il y a un
déséquilibre qui conduit à une baisse du
niveau de vie des retraités c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me permets de le
signaler et puis en dernier lieu j'ai
bien compris mais si j'ai bien compris
parce que hier il y a quand même eu des
avancées puisque j'ai vu que sur cette
partie gauche de l'équilibre de
l'hémicycle vous étiez d'accord pour
envisager une fermeture des régimes
spéciaux dans quelques années
ce sont les amendements proposés donc et
en conséquence pour conclure monsieur le
Président vous ne souhaitez pas
équilibrer le système par répartition
par une mesure d'âge vous ne souhaitez
pas équilibrer demain le système par
répartition par une un niveau
complémentaire deux capitalisation en
conséquence c'est un équilibre
incontournable vous l'équilibrez par
l'impôt mais mes chers collègues
permettez-moi
permettez-moi de vous répéter un système
par répartition par définition doit être
majoritairement composée de cotisations
c'est un système contributif que le
système
distributif la note distributive qu'il
faut mettre à côté effectivement l'impôt
mais ça peut pas être la note dominante
sinon vous changez complètement ce
système par répartition merci
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président
trébriègement après c'est longs échanges
mais je crois utile sur cette demande de
rapport quant à la capitalisation dans
le cas d'un système pas répartition
juste un mot pour appeler que le
gouvernement à la fois par principe et
parce que nous n'avons pas voulu ouvrir
ce débat souhaite pardon un avis
défavorable à l'adoption de ses rapports
dire aussi que tous ces échanges
renvoient toujours à ce que je me place
souligner c'est à dire là la complexité
il y a un point qui m'a interpellé dans
le débat qui est le fait que certains
intervenants considèrent que la question
démographique ne se pose pas et que le
système n'est pas en danger je ne
reviens pas sur les débats que nous
avons eu au sujet du rapport du corps
mais le niveau de déficit est
suffisamment important pour que nous
puissions parler d'un système en danger
et la question démographique est majeure
et ce qui m'a amené à qualifier cette
réforme parfois la surprise du président
Cana dans un certain nombre de
déclarations à la presse c'est le fait
que l'ensemble des gouvernements
européens qui soient libéraux qu'ils
soient démocrate ont déjà procédé assez
Ré la plupart des pays européens des
âges de départ qui sont soit de manière
effective soit en perspective compris
entre 66 67 ans l'un d'entre eux a même
un âge de départ fixé à 70 l'Espagne
dont on nous fait souvent exemple à
fixer l'âge de départ à 67 ans il y a
déjà plusieurs années cela se met en
oeuvre et je dis dans un clin d'oeil aux
membres du groupe communiste mais
mon homologue il lambda Dias qui est
ministre du Travail en Espagne non du
Parti communiste a mis en oeuvre 1er
janvier dernier le passage de l'âge
légal en Espagne à 66 ans et 4 mois et
donc nous voyons bien que partout autour
de nous la prise en compte de la
démographie est faite et et déjà active
et oblige d'une certaine manière à
fournir plus de travail pour assurer
l'équilibre des retraites
on vouliez faire je suppose un rappel au
règlement oui monsieur le Président sur
la base de l'article 36 qui prévoit la
prise de parole des sénateurs et pour
faire référence à ce qui évoquait le
rapporteur René Paul Savary quand il a
eu quelques références si j'ai bien
compris cette pathologique
je le dis
l'occlusion pour certains et d'y
arriveral pour les autres non monsieur
le rapporteur nous ne sommes pas une
diarrhée verbale ce qu'on appelle
Laurion
nous faisons notre travail si ça vous a
dérangé que nous ayons trop parlé hier
ça permet de compenser ce qui s'est
passé de l'autre côté de l'hémicycle
j'en suis désolé merci je vous donne
l'acte de ce rappel au règlement nous
allons commencer je rappelle que je
donnerai la parole aux quatre collègues
qui sont inscrits au moment de l'examen
je crois que notre débat qui est un bon
débat y compris dans la dimension
médicale doit me semble-t-il être clair
nous allons commencer par un scrutin
public sur le sous amendement
4735 demander par le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen avec un double
avis défavorable le scrutin est ouvert
voilà les sénateurs sont donc en train
de procéder à inscrit un public ce qui
permet de faire voter l'ensemble des
sénateurs de l'hémicycle de se compter
autour et bien de cette proposition des
sénateurs LR2 d'ouvrir la réflexion de
demander un rapport pour bien voir
comment introduire une part de retraite
par capitalisation dans notre système
par répartition cela a été l'occasion
vous l'avez vu de longues explications
de vote notamment de la gauche et voilà
le scrutin est déjà terminé on va
entendre le résultat en quelques
instants
pour 91 contre 252 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté alors ensuite nous passons sur
l'amendement
adopter cette amendement de la droite
mais on avait vu que d'ailleurs et bien
toute une partie de la commission n'y
était pas favorable mais plutôt pour une
question de forme parce que on ne peut
pas faire de rapport avec ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale les votes continuent sur la
suite des sous-amendements de la gauche
scrutin public demander par le groupe
communique par le groupe geste par des
mois et
je rappelle le double avis défavorable
de la commission du gouvernement le
scrutin est ouvert
voilà vous voyez qu'il y a et bien à
nouveau inscrit un public qui est
demandé cette fois-ci par le groupe des
écologistes dans les écologistes qui eux
aussi ont et bien sous amendé cette
amendement pour dire leur opposition à
la retraite par capitalisation on a
notamment vu les sénateurs communistes
estimés que les fonds de pension qui
sont choisis très souvent anti
environnementaux on va avoir le résultat
dans un instant
344 exprimés 343 pour 91 contre 252 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté
nous allons maintenant avoir un scrutin
public demander par le groupe geste sur
le sous amendement
le scrutin est ouvert
voilà encore une fois un nouveau scrutin
public c'est et bien l'occasion de se
compter sur et bien ce débat qui a bien
opposé la droite et la gauche sur
l'introduction d'une part de
capitalisation dans notre système de
retraite par répartition cette fois-ci
et bien on voit les sous amendements
déposés par la gauche passer les uns
après les autres au scrutin public un
noté aussi et bien que la gauche a
profité de cette matinée pour largement
s'exprimer sur ces sujets et faire en
sorte de prendre de plus en plus de
temps sur ce débat
343 pour 91 contre 252 le Sénat n'a pas
adopté
nous allons passer exactement le même
vote tout à l'heure que que sur l'autre
amendement de la gauche on prend tout de
suite la direction de l'hémicycle ou en
fin de nouveaux amendements sont
examinés
ceux qui sont favorables sur l'adoption
de manifeste en levant la main
avis contraire
[Musique]
abstention il n'est pas adopté
il en est de même pour l'amendement
47 49
même vote
même vote nous allons passer
un amendement qui va être soumis aux
scrutin du public c'est le 1968 de
Monsieur
présenté par Monsieur
Husson là aussi à la demande du groupe
communiste républicain et citoyen
le scrutin est ouvert
cette fois-ci et bien c'est bien un vote
sur l'amendement qui a été défendu tout
à l'heure par Jean-François a eu son
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances et qui a été consignée par de
nombreux sénateurs de droite d'ombres
Bruno Retailleau pour rappeler là encore
à réfléchir à une part de capitalisation
dans notre système de retraite par
répartition on va voir le comment va se
dérouler ce vote cela risque d'être
intéressant on va voir comment vont se
partager et bien les sénateurs de droite
qui est plus proche de la position de la
Commission et ce et bien qui sont plutôt
bien sur la ligne de Bruno Retailleau on
va tout de suite entendre le vote dans
un instant
344 exprimés 289 pour 163 contre 126 le
Sénat a adopté et par congrès de
conséquence les autres amendements
tombent
[Applaudissements]
voilà et bien c'était très intéressant
effectivement un vote favorable le Sénat
donc adopté et bien cet amendement du
rapporteur général du budget
Jean-François Husson qu'appelle donc à
réfléchir avec un rapport et bien à
l'introduction d'une part de
capitalisation dans notre système par
répartition donc la position de la
droite sénatoriale les autres
amendements en conséquence qui sous
amende et bien cette âme en en sont donc
tombé voilà le Sénat a tranché nous dit
à présent Gérard Larcher donc un vote
intéressant à une vraie modification sur
le texte et qui était contre la vie de
la Commission et contre la vie du
gouvernement tout de suite retour au
débat dans l'hémicycle c'est Raymond de
poncemonge c'est notre écologiste qui
prend la parole soit créé pour
l'ensemble des travailleurs de la
deuxième ligne bien entendu dans chacune
de leurs branches
avec une négociation syndicale
donc il y a pas dans les 8 semaines du
confinement et ce sont ces travailleurs
qui ont continué à se rendre
quotidiennement à leur travail et à
l'époque le président Emmanuel Macron
disait il faudra nous rappeler
aussi que le pays aujourd'hui tient tout
entier sur des femmes et des hommes que
nous économies reconnaissent et
rémunèrent si mal
et nous répondions à l'époque
effectivement les distinctions sociales
ne peuvent être fondées que sur
l'utilité commune les mots c'est
français les ont écrit il y a plus de
200 ans nous devons donc aujourd'hui
reprendre le flambeau et donner toute sa
force à ce principe
ce sont selon les chiffres de l'INSEE
près de 4 millions et demi de salariés
du privé seraient concernés dans les
branches par ces métiers dits de
deuxième ligne
je dirais que ce sont et c'est important
pour la suite eux qui sont
majoritairement représentés comme les
travailleurs en inactivité à 60 ans et à
61 ans encore plus ce sont eux qui
majoritairement
subissent bien supérieur à la moyenne
des autres familles professionnelles les
accidents de travail et les maladies
professionnelles des métiers de deuxième
ligne au travailleur invisible on serait
tenté de dire la société est peu
reconnaissante alors oui monsieur le
Président puisque vous avez dit il nous
faudra nous rappeler et bien je vais me
permettre de vous rappeler effectivement
que c'est notre économie tient sur ses
salariés et qu'à 60 ans et bien avant il
faut qu'il soit en retraite anticipée
pour ne pas être cassé ou être dans le
sas de pauvreté et de précarité
alors la vie de la commission madame la
rapporteur général
n'est pas romain dans ces Monge à
travers la cet amendement alors c'est
vrai que on devrait se soucier
finalement de l'ensemble des
travailleurs pourquoi de la première la
deuxième la troisième ligne tous les
travailleurs méritent aussi que on
s'intéresse à leur sort et justement le
système de retraite par répartition
c'est justement s'intéresser à tous du
plus modeste à celui qui a le plus et à
l'instant on a une séquence intéressante
où on a vu les scrutins publics se
multiplier cela a d'ailleurs abouti
finalement à l'adoption de l'amendement
de Jean-François Husson qui était
notamment cocignier par le président du
groupe LR Bruno Retailleau et qui
prévoit donc la remise d'un rapport un
rapport pour réfléchir à introduire une
part de retraite par capitalisation dans
notre système par répartition 163 pour
contre 126 et Audrey c'était l'occasion
aussi de voir et bien un certain nombre
de scrutins publics s'égrainés
c'était d'ailleurs pas toujours facile
de s'y retrouver oui Tom peut-être que
notre spectateur s'en sont rendus compte
il y a plusieurs manières de voter soit
la main levée soit le scrutin public le
scrutin public c'est un vote
électronique les sénateurs utilisent
leur carte pour voter ça permet de
savoir qui votre quad de manière très
précise des vôtres qu'on peut retrouver
ensuite sur le site du Sénat ça prend
aussi plus de temps car il faut que tous
les sénateurs se déplacent pour aller
voter et ça permet de se faire à la
demande c'est un groupe qui demande et
vous avez peut-être pu voir tout à
l'heure que les groupes de la gauche ont
demandé des scrutins publics notamment
concernant l'amendement Husson pour
savoir quel sénateur nominativement
était pour ou contre l'introduction
d'une dose de capitalisation
merci merci beaucoup Audrey pour toutes
ces explications on va tout de suite
revenir dans l'hémicyclos c'est le
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales et Elisabeth Doisneau
qui est en train de s'exprimer
on en parlera pendant encore quelques
jours il faut regarder tous les
travailleurs et chacun mérite notre
attention merci je suis le ministre mais
ma vie je chanterelle pour expliquer son
et Madame pochetman j'en suis monsieur
chanterelle
je suis bien d'accord sur vos remarques
sur le niveau de salaire mais là l'objet
de mon amendement c'est sur la retraite
anticipée c'est le fait de pouvoir
partir avant et dans les catégories
actives effectivement il y avait ce
c'était tout simplement les catégories
actives la possibilité après un certain
nombre d'années dans ces catégories
actives d'activités de partir de façon
anticipée et de partir de façon
anticipée bien plus avant que les deux
ans au maximum qu'on nous propose dans
cette loi parce que dans cette loi ces
deux ans maximum avant 64 donc 62 ans
c'est pour ça que je vous disais qu'à 60
ans effectivement dans ces métiers là
une grande partie sont déjà soit en
activité en inactivité sous différents
sous différentes raisons ils sont soit
en maladie longue durée ils sont soit au
chômage ils sont soit au RSA où ils sont
dans l'autre minima social qui
la location Spécifique de Solidarité où
ils sont aussi massivement sans aucune
ressource parce que quelquefois ils ont
même été crachés de l'assurance chômage
avec 25 % maintenant de moins de temps
ou ils ont été radiés et on sait
maintenant la façon massive dont on
radie pour améliorer les chiffres du
chômage ou dans le cas ou des
allocataires donc là c'était de dire une
obligation de dans ses branches d'ouvrir
avec les organisations syndicales et
cette fois-ci sans les bipasser le
départ anticipé et bien au-delà je pense
pour ces métiers de deux ans la deuxième
chose que je dirais vous avez dit
pourquoi cela est pas les autres manger
plein d'amendements qui ont été
supprimés qui ont été radiés je parlais
de ceux de la première ligne je parlais
ceux de la deuxième ligne j'avais
d'autres rapports et c'est pour ça là où
celui-là c'est le survivant je sais pas
pourquoi il a survécu mais enfin bon
celui-ci celui de la deuxième ligne pas
d'autres demandes de d'explication de
vous madame Lindeman
oui chers collègues je crois que la
question posée par notre collègue
écologiste et tout à fait fondamental
elle a tout à fait raison de poser cette
question
parce que en effet l'allongement de la
durée de pour partir à la retraite va
percuter
principalement c'est salarié là et ils
n'ont pas besoin madame la rapportrice
de je ne sais quelle compassion de je ne
sais quelle charité le principe c'est de
créer des droits qui fasse qu'il puisse
partir en retraite et qu'il ne reste pas
dans cette zone grise où ils sont
précarisés pauvres ou bien quand il
travaille ils accentuent leurs problèmes
physiques et parfois moraux
donc moi j'insiste lourdement auprès de
nos collègues pour que cette mesure qui
est quand même si je puis dire
raisonnable puisque ce que propose notre
collègue c'est des négociations par
branche ou il devrait y avoir de chaque
branche la définition de ceux qui
peuvent profiter de cette retraite
anticipée je considère que c'est un
équilibre entre des droits généraux et
le rôle de la négociation sociale qui
souvent prévôt dans notre système et
enfin pour terminer vous nous avez tous
expliqué qu'il fallait faire des fonds
de capitalisation mais vous allez
augmenter les cotisations de ces gens
qui sont les travailleurs modestes sous
prétexte de faire de la thésaurisation
en leur nom en lui et place 2 puisque
vous font de capitalisation ils sont
abondés par des cotisations obligatoires
et par la même vous savez très bien
qu'au lieu de vous allez détourner cette
augmentation de cotisations que pour une
part nous jugeons raisonnable pour
abonder le fond de répartition vous
allez détourner pour l'entretenir de la
financiarisation vous ne contribuerez
pas à l'amélioration des retraites pour
les plus modestes et en particulier les
travailleurs dit essentiels
merci Monsieur gay
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues c'est un
amendement extrêmement intéressant posé
par nos collègues écologistes je vous ai
bien écouté madame la rapporteur il y a
aussi un chef d'entreprise assez connu
en France qui s'est exprimé sur ce sujet
s'appelle Patrick pouyanet PDG total
énergie le 8 février dernier une grande
interview aux Parisiens
et les trois dernières questions avaient
lieu enfin sur le sujet des retraites on
lui posait la question elle vous
favorable à reforme des retraites il dit
l'espérance de vie c'est
considérablement allongée et si on veut
sauver le système pareil partition il
faut aller à 64 ans
le journaliste répond sauf à augmenter
les cotisations patronales ouh là là non
sinon les entreprises investiront
ailleurs il y aura donc moins de jobs on
est en train de gagner la bataille de
l'emploi ce n'est pas le moment de tout
casser en revanche comme vous il dit il
faudrait un jour parler de retraite par
capitalisation en complément mais
j'avoue que c'est un sujet tabou
aujourd'hui et enfin il en vient que
pensez-vous de l'index des seniors voulu
par le gouvernement pour inciter les
entreprises à conserver les plus de 55
ans dans les entreprises
[Musique]
mes chers collègues évidemment on va
voter cet amendement parce que quand je
regarde et j'ai bien regardé tous les
métiers qui sont cités j'avoue que
l'histoire de deuxième ligne ça me
choque un peu mais peut-être que je suis
pas assez moderne et contemporain il y a
des métiers et les métiers c'est des
professions et moi je respecte les
métiers et les professions et ce qui a
été clairement fait dans l'amendement
mais écoutez vous avez supprimé monsieur
le ministre les critères de pénibilité
ça ça a été votre responsabilité tout le
monde le sait ici moi voilà vous avez un
ministère du Travail vous avez la DARES
qui nous dit que tous les métiers qui
sont cités ici agent d'entretien
conducteur de véhicule agent de
gardiennage et de sécurité bouchées
charcutier maraîchers
nous dit que c'est dans ces domaines et
ses activités professionnelles qui est à
plus d'accidents et de maladies
professionnelles donc mes chers
collègues on va leur mettre deux années
de plus
et on prendrait pas des mesures où on
ouvre des bases de négociation
collective
franchement et là il y a je ressens un
sentiment d'injustice pour eux merci
merci monsieur le Président hier
après-midi notre collègue Henri Cabanel
évoquait les difficultés d'attractivité
de certains métiers et disait justement
que certains métiers ne bénéficiaient
pas forcément des mesures qui étaient
prises par rapport à ce qui était mis en
cause hier après-midi et ici on voit que
des métiers essentiels
important sont en difficulté les
personnes qui pratiquent ces métiers et
bien ce sont les personnes qui sont en
grande souffrance et parmi lesquels les
agriculteurs nous avons eu ici même à
parler du nombre de suicides des
agriculteurs pourtant nous avons besoin
d'eux nous parlons de plus en plus de
l'alimentation de la qualité de la
l'alimentation et c'est important
aujourd'hui que nous puissions poser les
vrais problèmes parce que parler de
capitalisation c'est vrai on peut mais
quand on regarde les revenus des
agriculteurs qui se manifestent
régulièrement parce qu'ils n'ont pas
suffisamment revenu et qu'on baisse
c'est un super profit baisse les coûts
et les prix des produits alimentaires
produits par nos agriculteurs qui sont
déjà en grande difficulté quand on
regarde les problématiques de Claude
mais aussi de néonicotinoïdes qu'on a
ici même il y a peu de temps réintroduit
sans penser à la santé de ces personnes
alors que nous avons justement des
non-lieu pour ceux qui ont utilisé
encore des conneries se poser les un
vrai problème quand on parle des
problèmes des jeunes la tractivité des
métiers comment voulez-vous qu'ils
puissent vouloir travailler dans les
mêmes conditions que leurs parents ou
leurs grands-parents qui ont des petites
retraites qui ne réussissent même pas à
les nourrir à les aider et à les
encourager et même quand ils font des
études et des études supérieures qu'il
réussissent ils sont au chômage dans mon
territoire alors nous devons aujourd'hui
mettre à plat un certain nombre de
choses c'est vrai que l'amendement qui
est présenté ici nous permet de
réfléchir différemment mais nous devons
aussi voir quels sont nos propres
erreurs ici même sur ces mains dans les
deux trois années pour être précédentes
il y a eu une mission de formation
récente sur la santé mentale posons-nous
les vraies questions
merci madame la Présidente rossignol
quand
je rencontre à la santé le travail
dans les chaînes salariés de plus de 50
ans laisse durée des arrêts de travail
est plus élevée
86,9 jours par accident de travail pour
les 50 59 ans soit contre 79 jours pour
les 40 49 ans la durée moyenne d'un
arrêt maladie en France et 35 jours pour
l'ensemble des salariés et 75 jours pour
les salariés de plus de 60 ans 58% des
décès liés en accident du travail
58% la victime a plus de 50 ans alors
outre la dimension humainement cruelle
de ce que j'explique c'est
incontestablement un transfert de charge
de l'assurance vieillesse vers
l'assurance maladie c'est ça que votre
réforme et c'est pour ça que nous
voterons l'amendement de la pensée mange
nous allons maintenant procéder
monsieur Royer pardonnez-moi
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues
d'abord je voudrais rappeler que un
autre amendement le 3167 de ma collègue
qu'on se mange a été frappé d'y
recevabilité il parlait des salariés de
première ligne et je pense que quand on
s'intéresse à l'ensemble de ces salariés
qui sont ceux pour qui l'allongement de
la durée au travail aura les
conséquences les plus lourdes il serait
souhaitable que la l'attention que sur
tous les bancs on porte à ses salariés
ni de première et deuxième ligne se
traduisent dans un dans le vote de cet
amendement le corps évalue à un milliard
les coûts de transfert en direction de
l'assurance maladie liée à cet
allongement
du travail pour ces métiers les plus
pénibles je voudrais rappeler aussi que
au passage 20% des ouvriers sont morts
avant de bénéficier de leur retraite et
donc ne pas prendre en compte que ces
métiers qui ont vu les critères de
pénibilité
rotoqués ont besoin d'un accompagnement
spécifique serait être défaillant à
notre souci de justice sociale
merci monsieur le ministre que vous
vouliez à ce point éclairer le échanges
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
simplement trois trois points d'abord
pour dire que sur ces questions de
pénibilité de prévention de l'usure nous
aurons l'occasion à l'article 9 de
revenir sur la manière dont on peut
prendre en compte les critères
ergonomiques pour faire en sorte qu'il y
a prévention suivi médical renforcée
possibilité de départ mais au-delà de
cette volonté de tenir compte de ces
critères qui sont la cause de la plupart
des inaptitudes pour troubles
spéculo-squelettique et que nous voulons
ainsi traiter je voulais répondre à la
présidente Rossignol sur ces deux
interventions madame la Présidente vous
inquiétez du des effets de départ de
dépens de la branche vieis vers d'autres
branches comme des coûts sûrement pas
échappé nous y reviendrons là aussi je
pense à l'article 7 que nous maintenons
l'intégralité des âges de départ
anticipés pour les travailleurs exposés
l'amiante à 50 ans comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui pour les travailleurs en
situation de handicap à 55 ans comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui pour
l'invalidité à 70 ans à taux plein comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui en maintenant
des bornes d'âge anticipées à
l'identique alors que chaque réforme des
retraites qui avait amené un relèvement
de l'âge d'ouverture des droits c'était
traduite par un relèvement de l'âge à du
proportion des mêmes bornes nous évitons
ces effets de report d'une branche sur
l'autre la deuxième chose que je voulais
vous dire la présidente concerne les
accidents du travail vous avez évoqué
l'accidenté l'accidentologie pardon les
travailleurs les plus âgés derrière
chaque
cas il y a un drame donc il faut
toujours être prudent quand on s'exprime
à ce sujet là
vous avez notamment évoqué les accidents
gravés mortels c'est sur ce point là que
l'accidentologie est la plus forte or il
se trouve que si on neutralise en tout
cas assez statistiquement neutralise les
accidents du travail qui depuis 2019 a
prit une jurisprudence de la côte
cassation relève de malaise au travail
l'accidentologie des travailleurs
seniors est inférieur à l'actionologie
et travailleurs les plus jeunes il y a
dans les chiffres que nous utilisons
depuis 2019 une intégration des malaises
au titre des accidents du travail grave
aux immortels ce qui implique une
augmentation de l'accidentologie des
seniors quand on regarde et je reste sur
les accidents du travail mortel et
graves et quand je dis grave c'est
entraînant une incapacité permanente la
typologie des blessés ou malheureusement
des décédés sont des jeunes ou et c'est
la seule exception à ce principe d'âge
de nouveaux entrants non pas dans le
marché du travail mais sur le poste
travailleur détaché travailleur en
intérimaire nous vous recruter
travailleur en formation
et donc c'est une précision que je
voulais apporter mais on aura l'occasion
d'y revenir
non non non
nous allons procéder au vote j'ai été
saisi on pourra d'occasion d'y revenir
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public et de scrutin et tout vert
appelle qui porte sur l'abandon
de Raymonde Poncet Monge un cet
amendement du groupe et que le geste qui
voulait et bien créer un nouveau régime
spécial et bien pour les salariés de la
deuxième ligne à expliquer et bien tout
à l'heure la sénatrice écologiste et
vous avez entendu beaucoup de sénateurs
notamment à gauche un défendre cette
mesure parlant et bien de l'importante
pénibilité pour ces différents salariés
on parle de conducteur de véhicule
d'agent d'entretien de caissiers
d'employés de libre-service d'ouvriers
qualifiés de la manutention de vendeurs
en produits alimentaires de boucher
charcutier boulanger etc voilà le
scrutin est clos on va
344 exprimer 335 pour 92 contre 243 le
Sénat n'a pas adopté
cette amendement écologiste
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Jean-Baptiste Lemoine qui prend la
parole pour le groupe dessinateur
Renaissance le groupe destinateur RDPI
d'anticiper parce que nous nous penchons
là avec le présent projet de loi sur les
mesures visant à obtenir un équilibre à
2030 le corps travaille à une échéance
qui est plutôt celle de 25 ans donc
autour de 2050 voire plus 2070 et c'est
vrai que pour être porteur de confiance
et d'espérance je crois qu'il est utile
que nous puissions autour de 2027
mener un certain nombre de travaux
d'anticipation
parce que faute de quoi
depuis 30 ans on assiste à peu près à la
même chorégraphie tous les 7 ou 8 ans
avec un certain nombre de réformes qui
ont touché d'abord à la durée
d'assurance ensuite à l'âge légal et
l'idée c'est de commencer à
anticiper à préparer l'avenir
sachant que cela demande de la
créativité parce que après avoir atteint
avec la présente réforme 64 ans en
termes d'âge légal 43 ans en terme de
durée d'assurance sachant qu'on ne veut
toucher ni aux impôts naturellement ni
dégradé de niveau des pensions il est
important et bien de regarder quels sont
les leviers qui permettraient dans la
durée de maintenir cet équilibre à
échéance 2035 à l'échéance 2040 les
chances 2050 parce que le corps lui-même
le précise il y aura encore alors ces
simulations sont avant réformes mais il
y aura encore un certain nombre de
déficit s à long terme et donc c'est
l'objet de cet amendement de demander ce
rapport qui puis qui pourra donner lieu
à débat à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat anticiper ça a été dit sur de
nombreux bancs voilà tel est l'objet de
cet amendement monsieur
le rapporteur la vie
merci monsieur le Président chers
collègues nous n'avons pas eu plus
d'indulgence pour votre demande de
rapport que pour les autres en réalité
vous posez le problème effectivement de
la clause de revoyure en quelque sorte
alors on sera tous très friands
éventuellement des leviers qui seraient
trouvés pour justement cet équilibre
budgétaire et cette confiance dans notre
système de retraite aussi bien j'imagine
monsieur le ministre que l'ensemble des
Françaises et des Français et et des
parlementaires
quelle serait ses leviers moi je pense
qu'effectivement c'est un sujet
tellement important qu'il faut qu'on y
réfléchisse de façon annuelle qu'on
fasse une vraiment qu'on regarde
monsieur le rapporteur de la branche
vieillesse avec précision comment les
choses avancent et je voudrais revenir
sur cette ce rapport du corps du Conseil
d'orientation des retraites parce que
tout le monde le brandit tout le monde
le regarde d'une façon un petit peu
différente mais on voit bien on voit
bien sur ces courbes et je veux les
montrer je veux les montrer que de toute
façon et il y a cette pente vertigineuse
et d'ailleurs le corps lui-même le met
le système de retraite serait
déficitaire durablement il y a pas de
mystère il y a pas de mystère et tout le
monde peut le consulter tout le monde
peut le consulter et c'est avec des
prévisions à 4,5% de chômage ce qui est
très optimiste donc soyons soyons clairs
là-dessus on peut pas dire n'importe
quoi dans les médias tout le monde peut
consulter ce rapport et il est voilà
implacable donc si on veut effectivement
redonner de la confiance aux jeunes
notamment dans notre système par
répartition il faut qu'on agisse et vous
avez dit chers collègues parlons
d'anticipation vous avez raison c'est ça
qui a fait le Sénat depuis 4 ans ses
parents anticipation composé cet
amendement parce que la courbe la courbe
démographique le prouve et dans chacune
de nos familles on voit bien qu'on a
quatre à cinq générations nos parents
n'avaient que trois générations vivantes
avec plus d'actifs puisque plus
d'enfants et aujourd'hui on a moins
d'enfants le système c'est ça c'est ça
sa fragilité c'est la démographie ça a
été dit ce matin et je le redis il faut
agir aujourd'hui il est grand temps pour
que ça ne soit pas aussi brutal que vous
l'annoncez et donc c'est non pour votre
apport mais en tout cas le sujet était
évidemment d'actualité il faudra une
clause de revoyure merci
[Applaudissements]
la Commission n'a pas eu plus
d'intelligence pour votre demande de
rapport et le gouvernement n'a pas eu
beaucoup plus à vrai dire donc c'est une
demande de retrait je pense que la
perspective d'avoir des outils des
leviers et un système de pilotage plus
réel et même au-delà de plus réelle sur
plusieurs décennies est évidemment une
perspective qu'il faut partager je pense
aussi que nous aurons l'occasion dans
les cours de l'examen de ce texte de
revenir sur la clause de revoyure plutôt
à horizon 2027 pouvoir comment les
choses se sont mises sont mises en
oeuvre et comment le Parlement en a été
informé et je sais aussi votre intérêt
pour tous les leviers qu'on a évoqué
dans le débat précédent permettant
d'assurer une visibilité une viabilité à
long terme du système de retraite donc à
ce stade c'est une demande de retrait ça
n'enlève rien à l'importance qu'il y a à
travailler sur cette prévisibilité et
sur cette capacité à avoir des leviers
je dis en faisant une parenthèse
certains prennent parfois des
ajustements automatiques des systèmes de
retraite ça n'a pas ma préférence dans
la mesure où je pense que le Parlement
l'État ou la classe politique doit
rester souverain doit rester souverain
en matière tu es le moi
merci monsieur le président
général s'interrogeait sur les leviers
je veux dire que par exemple en 2033
nous savons que la cadèse viendra
échéance donc il y a des ressources qui
sont là qui sont importantes plus de 10
milliards d'euros
il y a des questionnements à voir sur
l'usage de ces ressources par rapport à
notre système de retraite
voilà il y a eu un débat précédemment je
n'y reviendrai pas mais tout ça pour
dire que il y a effectivement matière à
réflexion j'entends la demande de
retrait qui a été émise par le
gouvernement et donc de la même façon
que président Bilon évoquait les travaux
à venir peut-être de la commission des
finances de la commission des affaires
sociales nous avons ici au Sénat une
délégation la prospective c'est à
l'honneur de cette assemblée je forme le
vœu que peut-être la délégation puisse
aussi se pencher sur ce type d'enjeux à
long terme et donc au bénéfice de ces
travaux à venir je retire l'amendement
mais je voulais poser ce sujet de
l'anticipation et de la clause de
revoyure pour lequel j'étais entendu
outré donc
nous passons à l'article
sur lequel je vais donner la parole
immédiatement à Madame la rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales merci monsieur le Président
chers collègues je pense que nous allons
trouver finalement au moins un article
sur lequel nous serons tous d'accord ce
qui est assez
ce qui est assez étonnant contre le
gouvernement d'ailleurs donc on va
pouvoir peut-être se réjouir
collectivement en tout cas je dirais
simplement donc
en quelques mots sur cet article premier
bis dont l'avenir je vous le disais et
paraît mal assuré au vu du nombre
d'amendements qui proposent la
suppression je ne sais plus d'ailleurs
quel est leur nom mais en fait il est
important et je pense que chacun s'y
reconnaîtra il propose donc que le
gouvernement remettre dans un délai d'un
an un rapport au Parlement sur la
possibilité les conditions et le
calendrier de mise en oeuvre d'un
système universel de retraite c'est un
article qui a été ajouté à l'Assemblée
nationale alors c'est vrai que
on est on a parlé de la capitalisation
on parle de la répartition depuis
quelques jours déjà là on revient
finalement à la proposition d'un système
universel tel qu'il a été travaillé par
Jean-Paul Delevoye est-ce bien
nécessaire il y a trois ans seulement
rappelez-vous on en a beaucoup débattu
il y a eu des Colocs ici au Sénat René
Paul Savary mais Jean-Marie va
laurenberg également avait travaillé sur
le sujet je pense que là on est un petit
peu vraiment mais carrément exporter je
parlais tout à l'heure d'un petit déport
par rapport à l'objet de notre projet du
projet de loi mais là on est carrément
très à côté puis c'est surtout quelque
chose qu'on a déjà vu quoi on a déjà
parlé de ça donc il me semble que
cet amendement de suppression et
bienvenue et et que donc
si vous si vous le souhaitez chers
collègues on peut d'ailleurs considérer
que mon amendement de suppression vaut
pour tous les autres et le débat est
clos merci
[Musique]
je chanterai le vouliez faire un rappel
réglement non
madame Cathy a pour ce poli pour le
groupe communiste
je voulais faire un appel au règlement
que au nom de l'article 46 bis mais vous
l'aviez pas vu malheureusement monsieur
le Président parce que cet appel à
règlement je l'avais fait avant qu'on
entame parce que je voulais qu'on puisse
avoir la parole sur l'amendement de
Monsieur Lemoine nous étions plusieurs
parlementaires à souhaiter intervenir
donc je voulais faire l'appel à
règlement en reprenant cet amendement
pour que nous puissions justement en
discuter
oui mais je voudrais vous rappeler que
c'est moi qui organise les débats je
donne la parole
j'avais demandé la parole monsieur le
président
Madame A pour ce poli
merci monsieur le Président
l'article premier bis fait référence à
la réforme des retraites de 2019 qui
visait la mise en place d'un système de
compte notionnel à cotisation définie et
non plus aux prestations définies la
différence est de taille puisque cela
signifie que le taux des cotisations sur
salaire est en fixé une fois pour toutes
les droits à retraite peuvent être
automatiquement et uniformément réduit
pour établir l'équilibre financier du
régime le fonctionnement de ce système
plébiscité par le MEDEF et les
gouvernements européens a mis en place
en Suède en 2003 sur le recommandations
de Bruxelles dans ce système par point
les pensions sont la variable
d'ajustement ainsi si l'espérance de vie
moyenne augmente plus vite que prévu
voilà nous attaquons donc l'article
premier bis de ce projet de loi un
article qui a été pouvez rajouter entre
l'Assemblée et le Sénat un article qui
propose que le gouvernement remette dans
un délai d'un an un rapport au Parlement
sur la possibilité les conditions et le
calendrier de mise en œuvre d'un système
universel de retraite à savoir donc bien
le système qui était proposé en 2019 un
article issu d'un amendement du député
Renaissance marque ferrachi et donc
l'issue paraît écrite d'avance puisque
vous l'avez entendu à travers la prise
de parole d'Elizabeth Doisneau
rapporteur général de la commission des
affaires sociales et bien la Commission
demande sa suppression tout comme la
gauche et donc une fois n'est pas
coutume sur ce texte voilà une mesure
qui unit des voies de la gauche et de la
droite contre elle vous avez pu voir
boutade d'Elizabeth Doisneau qui a
proposé et bien que tout le monde se
range derrière son amendement de
suppression afin que l'on puisse
accélérer le rythme mais la gauche bien
sûr n'est pas d'accord là-dessus et donc
multiplie déjà les prises de parole sur
cet article premier bis et voilà donc et
bien l'oratrice du groupe écologiste
Raymond Poncet Monge qui s'exprime en
invalidité permanente effectivement si
vous aviez pas sorti par exemple la
validité permanente
du reportage il serait passé à 64 ans
comme les années précédentes et donc
vous auriez transféré effectivement
cette la charge à la branche maladie et
vous auriez économisé sur le versement
des pensions 3,1 millions puisque alors
qu'aujourd'hui à 62 ans il passe à la
retraite là il serait passé à
l'Assurance Maladie donc nous sommes
bien d'accord que dans ce cas là vous
n'auriez pas eu 17,7 millions
de gains par votre réforme mais plus 3 1
20,8 mais ça pas été le cas donc
effectivement c'est très bien il reste à
la retraite comme il était hier et donc
je vous rappelle qu'ils n'ont rien faire
dans la mesure d'accompagnement de 3,1
milliard que vous soustrayez à votre
gain puisque de fait il n'y a pas de
surcoût donc j'attends toujours la
réponse alors pour ce qui est donc le
gouvernement a tenté un système de
retraite universel son projet à point
s'est révélé dangereux puisqu'il
supprime je l'ai dit tout à l'heure la
partie du régime général de la retraite
par répartition un prestation définie au
profit d'un calcul de points dont la
valeur de service comme la
valeur d'achat enfin le prix d'achat
sont définis que chaque année dès lors
le caractère redistributif n'est pas
inscrit dans le mécanisme même de la
retraite par point purement
proportionnelle à la cotisation dans son
principe même c'est pourquoi on avait
évalué à une perte de 20% entre les
générations 61 et 90 si cette réforme
avait été matinée
d'un âge pivot voilà donc sur le
prétexte de simplification quelques fois
demander par la Commission européenne
cet article relance un débutant et qu'on
aurait vu tout totalement clos depuis
2020 madame
monsieur le Président chers collègues on
a un débat
qui va qu'il faut bien le mettre mais le
feu au pays
pour un système de retraite dont on nous
dit mais on ne comprend pas pourquoi les
Français se manifestent c'est tellement
indispensable et c'est tellement
consolidé le système par répartition que
finalement il y a une sorte il faudrait
leur expliquer alors on a on entend plus
ça ils ont compris que plus on
expliquait plus les Français étaient
contre
mais alors au même moment vous dites que
cette réforme c'est vraiment important
qu'elle
va du côté de la droite on dit ah non
non les gars de ce Nantes c'est qu'un
début ça il va falloir quand même
changer les choses alors selon le
vocabulaire en ajoutant une fusée
capitalisation etc puis du côté de la
République en marche on dit ah non non
mais cette réforme c'est bien mais quand
même faudrait peut-être réfléchir
au système de retraite par point
d’autose demande pourquoi s'il était si
intéressant monsieur Macron ne l'a pas
remis au moment de sa présentation aux
élections présidentielles parce que si
c'est vraiment bien ben il aurait pu
nous convaincre toute façon il aurait pu
nous faire le même coup qu'il fait
aujourd'hui vous m'avez lu pour ça donc
je le fais même si on sait que c'est pas
pour ça
ça veut surtout dire
sa consolide notre argumentaire que si
on doit discuter du système de retraite
on le fait pas
au détour d'un
plfssr on le fait pour un vrai débat de
retraite d'avenir
or nous nous assumons un débat d'avenir
parce que nous assumons le fait qu'il
faut mettre du carburant dans le moteur
de notre système de répartition et nous
faisons des propositions diverses et
variées complémentaires pas univoque
pour assurer un carburant durable avec
au regard des prévisions qui sont encore
merci
monsieur Lecomte
c'est le gouvernement qui a choisi le
véhicule législatif qui permet de porter
cette réforme des retraites en
l'occurrence l'article 47.1 alinéa 2 de
la Constitution donc
il ne devrait effectivement comme le dit
notre collègue marine proposait un une
réforme qui lui semble complète et utile
et définitive pour finalement donner
confiance à la population dans l'avenir
de notre système de retraite et pourtant
il apporte au Sénat alors que le texte
n'a pas été adopté à l'Assemblée
nationale un texte qui prévoit ce type
de disposition qui prouve qu'il n'a pas
confiance dans sa propre de sa propre
réforme j'ajouterai aussi que on espère
si jamais ça pouvait arriver que ce
rapport serait plus précis que l'étude
d'impact de
la réforme de 2020 mais de toute façon
tout ça n'est pas très important puisque
cet article qui prévoit un rapport
prospectif sur les conditions et le
calendrier de mise en œuvre d'un système
universel de retraite porte ne porte pas
sur l'application d'une loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale il
n'a donc pas sa place dans le plfsr en
l'application de l'article LO 111 3 12
du code de la sécurité sociale et je
crois que sur ce point nous serons tous
d'accord
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres mais mes chers collègues
j'ai regardé la présentatrice qui a été
fait par le député Renaissance à
l'Assemblée nationale je le cite
il nous faut continuer à améliorer le
système pour le rendre plus juste en
particulier nous devons ensemble
poursuivre la réflexion sur la
convergence des régimes et des règles
avec l'ambition de nous rapprocher d'un
système de retraite plus universel fin
de citation
c'était assez proche des propos du
président Retailleau et et notre
collègue rapporte en général Luçon
c'était très très proche
et je sais que le député nous savons
tous ce député très très très proche du
président Macron donc quelle est la
question
on est en train de d'avoir une majorité
qui nous dit on va passer au 64 ans les
43 à nuités mais ça suffirait pas il
faudra aller plus loin alors là
franchement là on a on a un moment
d'opacité totale
c'est quoi votre projet alors je le dis
à mes collègues de renaissance je le dis
au ministre je le dis aussi à mes
collègues de droite c'est quoi est-ce
qu'il faudra envisager de revenir à leur
retraite par point question je suis
obligée de la poser la question on n'a
pas la réponse et ce qui va falloir
trouver cette aménagement formidable
entre répartition et capitalisation et
puis troisièmement est-ce qu'il va
falloir continuer à supprimer des
régimes particuliers et puis allez on se
met à la quatrième question est-ce que
derrière vu qu'on nous a fait beaucoup
de comparaisons aux yeux du soft avec
l'Europe est-ce que en fin de compte
l'idée derrière c'est de passer assez
vite après la deuxième étage de la fusée
allez après 64 on pourrait faire un 65
ans 66 ans
donc voilà le but de cette de cet
article donc nous voterons la
suppression de cet article bien sûr
madame jasmin
merci monsieur le Président nous avons
évoqué ce matin les différents modèles
de capitalisation de répartition mais
lors de la discussion générale j'ai
évoqué les questions inhérentes à la
démographie la situation des jeunes le
chômage les conséquences sur la vie des
femmes sur le revenu et les toutes les
grandes disparités comment voulez-vous
que les jeunes se projettent dans un tel
contexte il leur est proposé
l'ubérisation quelques fois ils ne
travaillent mais ils ne sont pas payés
ils ne sont pas forcément déclarés la
crainte et l'incertitude permettent
justement au sondage de dire un peu
n'importe quoi mais la réalité est là
cette proposition va à l'encontre de
l'humanisation et de l'inclusion des
jeunes ils sont contraints de travailler
et beaucoup d'étudiants malheureusement
et on l'a vu lors de la pandémie se
suicide au temps de se suicider ils
n'ont plus d'espoir ils sont dans des
longues du resto du coeur ou dans les
CCAS nous devons protéger un système de
répartition pour la solidarité et je
dénonce justement monsieur le min Istre
le fait que les cabinets conseils vous
alimentent vous alimentent un élément
langage sans être efficient merci
madame la Présidente Laurence Rossignol
merci monsieur le Président en fait j'ai
mis quelques instants à comprendre quel
était le sens de cet article premier
bises je suis remontais un peu je fais
comme Pascal ça veut dire un instant et
qui était à l'initiative Marc Ferracci
très proche du président de la
République homme qualifié par les
biographies diverses de techno-libérales
techno-libérale c'est quand même un peu
la double peine moi de mon point de vue
technocrate et libérale et c'est un
techno libéral
nostalgique de la réforme à points qu'il
avait probablement dans ces moments
techno totalement conçu imaginé et
frustré
dans son versant libéral que la réforme
n'avait pas assez loin dans la
destruction notre système de retraite et
donc on voit bien j'arrive pas à
comprendre qu'elle est en fait la
proximité avec le président de la
République parce que ça rend nous
renvoie toute l'histoire de la réforme
des retraites la somme des mensonges je
retire mensonge pas d'ennuis je retire
mensonge des revirements des ambiguïtés
des changements de pieds des volts face
qui depuis 2017 accompagne les
déclarations du président de la
République et de ses proches sur la
réforme des retraites donc c'est
amendement ne présage rien de bon et je
voulais dire à Madame Doisneau que non
on va pas s'en tenir un débat parce que
c'est pas pour les mêmes raisons que
vous et moi et vous et nous on va le
retirer et j'en profite pour dire à nos
collègues que il faut pas croire tout ce
qu'on est dans le journal la Réforme
elle est pas de gauche vous pouvez
continuer de la soutenir comme vous le
faites avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme et
ne craignez rien vous ne voterez pas un
texte de gauche
madame
oui monsieur le Président moi je
m'interroge également sur l'arrivée de
de cet amendement
parce que
j'ai envie de dire qu'est-ce qu'on nous
cache encore qu'est-ce qu'on nous cache
est-ce qu'on nous cache que finalement
cette réforme ci qu'on va voter qui va
reculer de 2 ans l'âge de la retraite et
bien on l'a fait parce que parce que le
Président de la République veut
absolument montrer qu'il est capable de
réformer et qu'il n'a peur de personne
mais est-ce que derrière on n'aura pas
un nouveau projet de réforme des
retraites qui ira bien au-delà et
qu'elle est effectivement l'étage
suivant si on peut dire de la fusée
moi je trouvais la mandement de Monsieur
Lemoine tout à fait intéressant
d'ailleurs c'est dommage qu'il est qu'il
est enlevé parce qu'effectivement on
comprend tout ce que aujourd'hui c'est
64 ans mais si demain le pire n'est
jamais certain le meilleur non plus j'en
conviens si demain la situation on est
donc en train de commencer l'article
premier bis de ce projet de loi et on
entre la multiplication des prises de la
parole notamment de la part de la gauche
sur cette mesure à cet article premier
bis qui a été proposé par le député
Renaissance marque ferrachi qui veut
continuer à réfléchir à un système de
retraite universel par point et qui
propose et bien donc l'idée d'un rapport
sur le sujet et Audrey et bien on a
entendu et bien de très nombreuses
prises de parole qui sont encore en
train de continuer actuellement oui Tom
au spectateurs l'auront peut-être
remarqué depuis le début de l'examen du
texte les groupes de gauche multiplient
les prises de parole un exemple sur
l'article premier bisque nous sommes en
train d'examiner ils ont déposé des
dizaines d'amendements à raison de deux
minutes pour défendre chaque amendement
vous le voyez nous allons avoir
plusieurs heures de débat sur ce sujet
et quand la rapporteur général Doisneau
a essayé d'accélérer les débats parce
qu'en fait sur ce point tout le monde
est d'accord au Sénat gauche comme
droite pour supprimer cet article et
bien on lui a opposé une fin de
non-recevoir à gauche on justifie de
parole en expliquant nous on prend le
temps de débattre l'assemblée ne l'a pas
fait nous avons besoin de débattre pour
les français même si en coulissent
certains nous confient qu'ils essayent
de temporiser avec un objectif éviter
que l'examen de l'article 7 celui sur
l'allongement de des parents retraite
soit fait avant la grande journée de
mobilisation du 7 mars merci merci
beaucoup Audrey effectivement il y a à
la fois le débat de fond le débat là en
l'occurrence autour de la possibilité de
réfléchir et bien à un système universel
par point et tout cela et bien et
mélanger avec et bien de la tactique
politique et effectivement la gauche
multiplie les prises de parole les
amendements objectifs et bien débattre
de l'article 7 après la mobilisation de
mardi ça sera certainement en le cas
dans la nuit de mardi à mercredi on nous
annonce une nuit très longue mais en
attendant et bien la gauche est toujours
aussi présente dans l'hémicycle et c'est
à présent la sénatrice écologiste
Mélanie Vogel qui est en train de
prendre la parole tout de suite donc on
prend la direction de l'hémicycle re-
proposez-nous un texte et d'ici là je
crois qu'on n'a pas besoin de voter ce
texte
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre n'a été dit précédemment si on
veut discuter réellement d'une réforme
du système de retraite et bien il faut
un vrai projet de loi et pas une
proposition un projet de loi pardon
finance rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale au détour de de votre texte de
ce texte d'un article un article premier
bis et bien vous proposez donc la remise
d'un rapport tout cela pour évoquer
effectivement d'autres possibilités
d'organisation de notre système de
retraite mais alors dans ce rapport il y
a vraiment rien qui va le gouvernement
se donne un nom pour ébaucher une
réforme un an mais c'est
particulièrement course d'être dit quand
on sait qu'on a cité la Suède tout à
l'heure c'est au bout de 15 années que
ils ont proposé est mis en place une
nouvelle organisation le gouvernement
souhaite donc passer par un rapport qui
ne garantit aucunement aucunement
concertation la négociation le dialogue
social alors on a bien vu aussi que pour
vous le mot concertation n'a pas le même
sens que pour nous ou pour beaucoup
d'entre nous concertation avec les
organisations syndicales
particulièrement pour cette réforme vous
dites les avoir conviés à de réunions
mais vous n'avez absolument rien entendu
ou voulu au régner en écoutez de leur
revendications qu'il portait au nom des
salariés et aujourd'hui et demain et
bien ce sont encore des milliers et des
millions de Français qui vous diront que
cette réforme ils n'en veulent pas alors
vous avez encore le temps de la retirer
vous avez encore le temps de se dire ou
de vous dire de nous dire et bien oui
nous avons enfin entendu les Français le
peuple français et nous retirons cette
réforme
monsieur chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président en fait cet
article qui il nous explique qu'il
faudrait que l'on étudie la mutation
profonde de notre système de retraite et
que l'on envisage un calendrier pour le
transformer en régime universel à point
nous avons passé l'essentiel du
quinquennat précédent sur cette chimère
voulue par Emmanuel Macron et qui était
inscrite d'ailleurs à son à son
programme cet article finalement c'est
c'est un aveu de d'une faiblesse la vœu
d'une défaillance parce qu'un
haut-commissaire a travaillé sur cette
question des mois durant parce qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale il y avait même
une commission spéciale qui a été
constituée pour travailler sur ce projet
malgré cela le gouvernement est arrivé
au constat que le projet de loi était
inabouti et qu'il ne fonctionnait pas et
le covid vous a servi de prétexte pour
le retirer et il était tombé finalement
dans les oubliettes de l'Histoire et
lors d'une soirée obscure à l'Assemblée
les réapparu tout d'un coup alors
pourquoi remettre le sujet sur la table
au détour du projet de loi d'où on nous
discutons aujourd'hui s'il vous ne
revenez pas devant les Français avec
cette réforme voulue par Emmanuel Macron
soit on en parle plus
mais lorsque vous tentez de remettre
l'ouvrage sur le métier au travers d'un
article additionnel proposant un rapport
nous pouvons clairement pas vous suivre
si nous partageons l'idée qu'il faut un
système de retraite plus juste voire
plus universel si cela signifie qu'il
prendrait mieux en compte la pénibilité
des différents métiers la réforme que
vous proposez aujourd'hui en tout cas
fait exactement l'inverse
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre messieurs les ministres
pardonnez-moi mes chers collègues bon il
y a les bons et les mauvais rapports
je vois qu'on va faire le tri bon
celui-là il est extrêmement mauvais
je le lis dans un délai d'un an à
compter la promulgation de la
présente-toi le Gouvernement remet au
Parlement rapport sur la possibilité les
conditions et le calendrier de mise en
œuvre d'un système universel de retraite
faisant converger les différents régimes
et intégrant les paramètres de la
réforme prévue par la présente loi bon
ben tout est dit
ce que nous sommes en train de faire
aujourd'hui n'est qu'une étape
et donc dans un an va revenir sur
l'établi la retraite par capitalisation
le projet que vous n'avez pas lâché de
2019 personne a un poisson rouge ici qui
tombe dans un bocal et qui ont quelques
secondes oublie tout
en 2019 vous étiez bien pour la retraite
par capitalisation
et vous avez pas changé
d'autant plus que cet article premier
bis comme tout le monde sait ici qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale les débats n'ont
pas été au bout et que vous avez donc
transmis le texte par l'État vous avez
pu prendre et explorer ce que vous
vouliez vous avez repêché l'article 2
sur l'index qui avait été refusé et cet
amendement de notre de notre collègue
Marc Ferracci du groupe Renaissance à
l'Assemblée nationale il a été repêché
[Musique]
ché et donc
c'est que vous partagez en réalité cette
amendement et donc la perspective d'ici
un an de revenir avec un vrai projet de
loi par capitalisation c'est écrit sinon
vous auriez pu experger il me reste
encore 2 secondes mais je voulais rendre
monsieur le Président merci de cette
bonté madame le verrou
merci monsieur le Président donc après
une discussion approfondie sur la vision
d'une retraite par répartition et par
capitalisation par cet article adopter à
l'Assemblée nationale le gouvernement
nous invite à réfléchir aux conditions
et aux calendrier de mise en oeuvre d'un
système universel de retraite c'est donc
une porte ouverte au régime de retraite
par point dit universel que le Président
de la République avait porté lors de son
premier quinquennat les Français et les
Français avaient massivement exprimé
leur opposition à ce projet de réforme
mais vous avez de la suite dans les
idées nous aussi et les Français aussi
souvenez-vous de cette grève mémorable
de fin 2019 début 2020 pendant laquelle
la SNCF la RATP ont battu le record des
jours de grève consécutifs avec
respectivement 53 jours et 49 jours de
grève déjà à l'époque c'est une réforme
des retraites voulues par le président
qui avait provoqué la colère de nombreux
secteurs et des Français c'est la crise
sanitaire du covid-19 qui avait permis
de tirer un trait sur cette réforme
ultra ibérale aujourd'hui vous remettez
le sujet sur la table au détour d'un
article du pnfss rectificatif dont le
l'objet ne devrait pas être celui-là
aujourd'hui donc vous demandez à nouveau
un rapport cette demande démontre
combien vous n'êtes pas prêt vous n'êtes
pas prêt à faire cette réforme donc
retirer l'un et remettez tous les
partenaires autour de la table pour une
négociation et non une imposition madame
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président alors que
nous discutons d'un projet repoussant
l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans que vous
avez appelé la mère des réformes voilà
quand vous nous proposez au détour de
ces articles un bis un rapport au
Parlement qui pourrait faire rentrer par
la fenêtre le rapport qui a été évacué
le projet qui a été vacu par la porte en
2019 sur le système universel de
retraite je n'évoquerai pas le temps
très court que vous évoquez dont vous
parlez dans ce rapport ça a été dit par
ma collègue Corinne Ferret la Suède a
travaillé pendant 15 ans avec la
co-construction pour aboutir en système
mixte et ça a été rappelé aussi l'ex
directeur de la sécurité sociale de
Suède nous a bien dit qu'il ne fallait
pas suivre cet exemple je n'évoquerai
pas non plus le fait que dans votre
rapport on ne sait qui le fera il n'y
aura ni co-construction ni les
organisations syndicales ni le Parlement
ne sont cités en tout cas cette demande
de rapport montre que vous n'avez pas
vous-même confiance dans le système que
vous voulez nous imposer contre la vie
de 110% de la population aujourd'hui ce
report à 64 ans et que vous savez déjà
envisagé la retraite par point
qui elle-même avait été retiré en 2019
donc c'est l'occasion puisque vous
n'êtes pas prêt de dire que vous arrêtez
votre réforme
madame de la contrée
merci monsieur le Président je dois dire
que c'est tout de même assez étonnant la
séquence et le donc le débat intéressant
que nous avons ce matin parce que bon
nous avons des désaccords sur le projet
de retraite qui nous est proposé
aujourd'hui
on a eu un débat intéressant sur la
capitalisation mais pourquoi le
gouvernement a-t-il voulu retenir ce qui
n'était pas dans son texte initial dans
un projet de loi initial la version qui
nous est soumise aujourd'hui
bénéficie d'un ajout ça a été rappelé
tout à l'heure proposé par Marc Ferracci
qui est un très très très proche du
président de la République sur la
retraite à points et là comment dire on
voit un gouvernement qui est quand même
on va dire un petit peu en difficulté
sur cette réforme des retraites on se
souvient 2019 on se souvient des
manifestations
la crise covid formidable a permis le
retrait de ce texte on se souvient de
l'âge pivot
de finalement de ceux qui se sont
trouvés victimes de cette réforme
monsieur dolvoye dont on a plus entendu
parler depuis monsieur pietrazevski dont
moi-même j'avais oublié qu'il avait joué
un rôle dans cette affaire
Édouard Philippe qui lui-même n'avait
pas le même avis que le Président de la
République sur ce sujet mais qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont venus faire dans cette
galère
pourquoi faire revenir aujourd'hui le
sujet de la retraite à point comme si la
galère n'était pas suffisamment chargée
déjà rappelons qu'à l'époque la CFDT qui
était prête à discuter sur la question
de la retraite à point lorsque là je
pivot est arrivé à basculer dans le camp
des opposants alors est-ce que le
gouvernement s'est dit de toute façon la
CFDT est déjà opposant aujourd'hui
finalement on n'a pas grand chose à
perdre mais voilà la démarche que j'ai
envie de dire psychologique aux
politiques je dois dire on a déjà dit
ici que c'était des génies tactiques
mais là je veux dire qu'on touche quand
même au sublime
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
moi j'ai un problème de droit de droit
constitutionnel le gouvernement nous a
dit qu'il utilisait la procédure du 47-1
parce qu'il y avait l'urgence ce qui est
parfaitement justifié c'est l'objectif
du 47 ans or vous nous dites maintenant
qu'il faut absolument un rapport qui
soit rendu dans moins d'un an pour que
le gouvernement puisse nous présenter de
nouveau une proposition de loi je vous
pose la question monsieur monsieur le
ministre pourquoi vous donner
aujourd'hui dans cette hémicycle des
arguments de censure au Conseil
constitutionnel merci monsieur le
président
nous allons passer maintenant à l'examen
des amendements nous en avons un certain
nombre
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
commune
tout d'abord l'amendement numéro
310 rectifiés que présente monsieur
Bilon et Monsieur Arthaud monsieur Milon
oui merci merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres madame la
Présidente de la Commission je cet
amendement propose donc la suppression
de cet article qui pourrait s'imposer
pour au moins trois raisons il constitue
sa déjà été dit un cavalier social qui
n'a pas sa place dans le loi de
financement rectificatif de la sécurité
sociale pour 2023 en espèces le rapport
prévu sur la mise en oeuvre du système
universel de retraite n'a pas pour objet
d'améliorer l'information et le contrôle
du Parlement sur l'application des lois
de financement de la sécurité sociale
c'est un c'est une décision du Conseil
constitutionnel du 13 décembre 2012
cette disposition est aussi une
tentative de revenir à une réforme
systémique du système de retraite fondée
sur un régime universel par point en
pleine contradiction avec tout le reste
du projet de loi qui met en oeuvre une
réforme paramétrique portant sur l'âge
d'admission et la le nombre d'années
d'annuités nécessaires le gouvernement
avait proposé un système en 2019 il a
été contraint de le retirer le rapport
proposé par l'Artic premier bis cherche
à faire revenir par la fenêtre ce que
nous avons fait sortir par la porte et
puis le troisième question importante
cet article indice cherche à rétablir
l'unification du recouvrement social qui
s'inscrivait dans le cas du système
universel de retraite or ce transfert
aux URSSAF de l'activité de recouvrement
d'agirco a été repoussé à plusieurs
reprises par le Parlement et
dernièrement encore il a été repoussé
dans le cas de la loi de financement la
sécurité sociale 2023 je vais m'arrêter
là en respectant donc les dires du
président kaner qui demandent qui nous a
dit que la parole était d'argent et je
dirais qu'on est en cours le silence
peut être d'or
un briquet
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues cet article
prévoit que dans un délai d'un an à
compter de la promulgation de la
présente loi le gouvernement remette au
Parlement un rapport sur la possibilité
les conditions et le calendrier de mise
en oeuvre d'un système universel de
retraite faisant converger les
différents régimes en intégrant les
paramètres de la réforme prévue dans le
présent texte
veut-on suivre ici l'exemple suédois
évoqué plutôt dans nos débats et dont le
résultat a été l'abandon du régime par
répartition système suédois aujourd'hui
dénoncé par cela même qui l'ont mis en
place
pour rappel aussi le précédent projet de
loi de réforme des retraites qui devait
nous faire basculer sur un système
universel a été massivement rejetée par
les Français ça a été rappelé par mes
collègues tout à l'heure il me semblait
par ailleurs que la première ministre
avait écarté la retraite par point il y
a quelques semaines cet article n'a donc
pas lieu d'être il n'a pas sa place non
plus dans le texte dont nous discutons
aujourd'hui et auquel nous nous opposons
comme une grande majorité de Français ce
serait là une double peine le recul de
l'âge de la retraite et le glissement
vers un système par capitalisation une
course à l'injustice sociale au mépris
des Françaises et des Français pour ces
raisons nous demandons la suppression de
cet article
madame Ferret
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre donc cet amendement porte sur
l'article premier bis pour lequel nous
proposons donc sa suppression ce texte
était transmis au Sénat enfin le texte
sur lequel nous discutons nous des
bâtons intègre donc ce nouvel article
qui est issu comme cela a été rappelé
d'un amendement qui était adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale peut considérer
que ainsi le gouvernement revient par la
fenêtre avec cet article alors que les
Français avaient massivement rejeté en
2019 le projet porté par le gouvernement
de l'époque et qui a obligé ainsi avec
ce rejet massif obligé le président de
la République à retiré son texte alors
aujourd'hui nous faisons le constat que
non seulement le gouvernement ne veut
rien entendre sans tête encore et
toujours mais aussi d'une certaine façon
ça a été dévoilé ou révéler par notre
collègue trompe à nouveau les Français
parce que avec ce rapport et bien cela
peut laisser penser que demain
après-demain c'est un autre système de
retraite qui pourrait être mis en œuvre
merci monsieur le Président de monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues on peut
dire que à travers cet article on ajoute
de la confusion à la confusion le
système de retraite à points a été
rejeté en janvier la première ministre
signe la mise en œuvre du régime de
retraite que nous connaissons que nous
dont nous débattons et tout d'un coup
réapparaît cette suggestion de régime de
retraite universel qui a été rejetée
massivement par par les Français et en
fait je pense que cette séquence ou ce
tunnel de 10 jours de discussion sur les
retraites que nous connaissons
actuellement va se poursuivre tout au
long de l'année puisque l'objectif est
quand même très très clair de la part de
notre gouvernement c'est d'arriver à
plus ou moins long terme un régime qui
prendrait du paramétrer qui prendrait de
l'universel mais qui surtout nous
amènerait à la capitalisation donc cet
amendement comme objectif de supprimer
l'article concerné merci le chanterelle
merci monsieur le Président je crois que
depuis ce matin les débats sont assez
éclairants puisque on a longuement parlé
de de la capitalisation que que vous
défendiez du régime par capitalisation
après nous avons eu un amendement
d'appel de Monsieur Jean-Baptiste
Lemoine soutien du gouvernement qui
demandait justement les moyens qui
pourraient être prises après éventuelles
adoption de la réforme pour ne pas
reculer à nouveau l'âge de départ à la
retraite et ensuite nous avons cet
article qui souhaite premier bis qui
souhaite être ajouté derrière ça
justement il y a il y a un combat
idéologique qui a été très bien décrit
par mes collègues c'est la
capitalisation c'est le régime par
capitalisation nous en revenons encore
finalement c'est ça que vous avez
derrière à l'esprit c'est pas c'est pas
un régime universel mais c'est la
capacitalisation moi je vais vous parler
justement de ce que c'est d'un fond de
pension je connais bien puisqu'il est
canadien c'est CP PIP
en 2013 il a acquis 15% du capital
d'Orpea le tristement célèbre groupe qui
gère plus de 300 EHPAD maison de
retraite et haute cliniques dans notre
pays pour près de 320,8 millions d'euros
et que croyez-vous qu'il est arrivé
après cette année d'entrer au capital
d'Air et bien l'investisseur a demandé
un retour sur investissement
immédiatement optimisation des profits
d'orpa il a fallu réduire la masse
salariale augmenter les cadences faire
des économies surtout les équipements
les matériels la nourriture le personnel
et surtout le temps la suite nous la
connaissons nous l'avons tout et tous lu
dans le livre enquête les fossoyeurs le
scandale des méthodes de soins et de
gestion du groupe ORPEA les
maltraitances les comportements
négligeants la facturation de confort
hôtelier hors de prix aux patients mais
aussi les pressions managériales et des
actes de discrimination syndicale et le
tout avec des aides de l'État quelque
part c'est ça que vous proposez c'est
d'engraisser les proportions avec les
cotisations des travailleurs et
travailleuses et financer finalement la
maltraitance des retraités
il est défendu monsieur Redon Sarrazy
n'est pas là
on a le héros
alors l'amendement 672 que je vous
présente à l'article premier bis propose
de supprimer donc cet article la
retraite et le régime de retraite à
point dit universel a été rejeté
massivement par les Français lors du
premier quinquennat Macron nous l'avons
déjà dit obligeant le président de la
République et son gouvernement alors à
abandonné son texte le covid a été sur
ce point un bon prétexte qui a sauvé
notre président mais aussi les Français
qui ont avaient compris que ce sujet
était clos et non pourtant le 10 janvier
dernier en présentant une nouvelle
réforme des retraites cette fois-ci
paramétrique Elisabeth borne semblait
avoir signé elle-même la reine morte
définitive de la retraite à points il
n'y avait donc pas lieu d'agiter de
nouveau le spectre d'une future mise en
oeuvre d'un système universel de
retraite intégrant qui plus est les
paramètres de la réforme prévue par la
présente loi les Français ont clairement
exprimé qu'ils ne veulent aucune des
deux ni celle de 2019 ni celle que vous
vous
présentez aujourd'hui au détour d'un
PLFSS rectificatif non seulement le
gouvernement ne veut rien entendre et
sans tête à ponctionner un impôt de 2
ans sur la vie des Français avec la
retraite à 24 ans à 64 ans pardon
dès 2004 mais il leur dit en plus qu'au
lieu d'une réforme ils vont en avoir
deux le report de l'âge et le retour de
la capitalisation les Français voient
cette tergiversation de forme comme de
la provocation merci Madame la triche
compta
alors qui merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
c'est un amendement également de
suppression de 7 article 1 bis au cours
du quinquennat précédent le président de
la République a tenté une première fois
d'habiller son premier projet de réforme
à finalité essentiellement budgétaire
déjà d'un vernis systémique en
introduisant une discussion sur l'idée
d'une retraite à points les Français ne
s'y sont pas laissés tromper ils ont
massivement rejeté ce projet l'état
l'opinion suite l'urgence de l'épidémie
de covid ont contraint Emmanuel Macron
assure soit à ce projet
à l'évidence si l'on en croit ce nouvel
article indice il n'a pas renoncé mais
les Français ne renoncent pas non plus à
le combattre cela a été dit si le régime
à points est théoriquement plus simple
rien ne garantit les droits des
retraités en réalité on le sait la
valeur du point pour être ajustée pour
équilibrer le système ce qui de facto
retireraient toute assurance au
retraitée sur le montant de leur futur
pension
donc cet article prétend ouvrir la
perspective d'une convergence à terme
des différents systèmes mais il exige
tout d'abord d'avalise en amont la
présente réforme qui nous est proposée
et dont massivement les Français et
nous-mêmes ne voulons pas et il fait
peser à nouveau un risque sur les futurs
niveau de pension donc nous demeurons
bien entendu ouvert à des évolutions
lorsqu'elles sont nécessaires d'une part
lorsqu'elles sont correctement et
sincèrement engagées d'autre part ici
avec cet article indice ce n'est pas le
cas nous nous y opposons
Monsieur Laurent de l'amendement 758
rectifié
oui monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues cet amendement pour objet de
supprimer l'article indice dont
l'objectif est de prévoir une étude un
an après la promulgation de la loi de la
convergence des régimes de retraite vers
un régime universel de retraite dans le
dossier de presse portant sur le projet
de loi actuelle il était indiqué que les
régimes autonomes tels que les
professions libérales et avocats et ce
répondant à des suggestions spécifiques
telles que les marins l'Opéra de Paris
la Comédie Française ne seront pas
concernés par cette fermeture
amendement 850 monsieur blanc
le il est défendu un moment 814 monsieur
Jacquin
monsieur le Président rénal pour
l'amendement 985
oui également pour évidemment soutenir
cet amendement de suppression mais je me
tourne vers vers mes collègues galères à
la et de la majorité sanatoriale plus
largement
parce que je trouve que cette matinée
est quand même dure pour eux je partage
je voudrais partager un instant cette
dureté avec eux il y a quand même
plusieurs sujets premier sujet nous
avons tout à l'heure le ministre Lemoine
qui nous dit globalement on a mal
travaillé on n'ont pas le travailler
parce qu'on a besoin de tout rouvrir et
c'est vrai on a mal travaillé et
d'ailleurs vous partagez cette position
on n'a pas fait en amont toutes les
diligences notamment on le sait sur les
écarts de salaire homme femme sur la
question des seniors enfin sur des tas
de sujets sans parler même des questions
de financement de nouveaux que l'on vous
a proposé donc effectivement
Jean-Baptiste Lemoine j'allais dire très
gentiment dit bon essayons de faire
mieux la prochaine une fois et de
travailler en amont bon ça veut dire
qu'on n'a pas très bien travaillé ce
coup-ci et pourtant vous allez soutenir
comment dire ce travail mal fait un peu
bâclé même s'il y a eu s'il y a quand
même eu 6 ans pour le préparer 6 ans 6
ans on a pas traité des sujets
finalement on n'a pas traité des sujets
de faux alors maintenant on vous dit
aidez-nous à voter ce texte mais ce
texte là c'est vraiment la comment dire
un pis aller et demain on va rouvrir les
vrais sujets quoi la retraite à point
donc la Russie ça a quand même de quoi
interroger en tout cas moi ça
m'interroge et je suis sûr que vous
aussi ça vous intéresse donc nous avons
sur l'ensemble de ces sujets des
difficultés qui sont donc considérables
à pouvoir avancer à comprendre
finalement où l'on veut nous amener mais
fort heureusement finalement vous allez
passer c'est de ça et j'allais dire que
comment dire la presse ce matin vous
donne un troisième moment quand même
d'interrogations vous vous prêtez donc
vous vous apprêtez donc on l'a dit à
voter comme l'a dit le ministre une
réforme de gauche je veux dire ça fait
beaucoup quoi ça fait beaucoup une
réforme de gauche mal préparée et qui va
être remplacer demain on vous donne
vraiment toutes les occasions de voter
contre voilà on voit les sénateurs de
gauche qui se succèdent pour défendre
leurs amendements qui est toujours le
même Satan amendement de suppression de
cet article premier bis cet article qui
propose que le gouvernement remette dans
un délai d'un an un rapport au Parlement
sur la possibilité les conditions et le
calendrier de mise en oeuvre d'un
système universel de retraite Audrey on
voit il y a de très nombreuses
amendements de suppression qui sont plus
ou moins les mêmes sur cette partie du
texte
et une fois n'est pas coutume le Sénat
dans son ensemble est plutôt d'accord
pour supprimer cet article premier bis
qui a été introduit par le gouvernement
entre l'Assemblée et le Sénat il prévoit
vous l'avez dit la création d'un rapport
sous un an pour étudier la possibilité
de mettre en place un système universel
des retraites sur le modèle de la
réforme qui était prévue en 2019
souvenez-vous ça avait aussi donné lieu
à d'importantes mobilisations le
gouvernement avait finalement abandonné
cette réforme vous l'entendez il y a de
nombreuses prises de parole il y en a eu
notamment de la sénatrice socialiste
Corinne Ferret qui critique un
gouvernement qui n'écoute rien écouté
le considérer que ainsi le gouvernement
revient par la fenêtre avec cet article
alors que les Français avaient
massivement rejetés en 2019 le projet
porté par le gouvernement de l'époque et
qui a obligé ainsi avec ce rejet massif
obligé le président de la République à
retirer son texte alors aujourd'hui nous
faisons le constat que non seulement le
gouvernement ne veut rien entendre sans
tête encore et toujours mais aussi d'une
certaine façon ça a été dévoilé ou
révéler par notre collègue trompe à
nouveau les Français parce que avec ce
rapport et bien cela peut laisser penser
que demain après-demain c'est un autre
système de retraite qui pourrait être
mis en oeuvre la Commission est pour la
suppression de cet article elle devrait
être suivie sauf surprise par le Sénat
merci merci beaucoup Audrey pour toutes
ces explications on entend effectivement
notamment la gauche qui s'interroge sur
les intentions du gouvernement ils
estiment que derrière la retraite
universelle par point il y a et bien la
retraite par capitalisation qui pointe
le bout de son nez également et puis on
arrive effectivement également entendu
des prises de parole à droite notamment
à l'ancien président de la commission
des affaires sociales à la Milan qui est
un peu exactement la même image que
Corinne Ferret disant là du corps et
bien que le gouvernement cherchait à
faire revenir par la fenêtre une réforme
qui était partie pourtant par la porte
la réforme de 2019 qui prévoyait donc la
retraite universelle par point et bien
continue tout de suite à suivre les
prises de parole de ses amendements de
suppression dans l'émission ce sont les
communistes qui ont actuellement la
parole les Français se prennent de
passion pour notre travail et nous
écoutent et donc je ne veux pas passer
mon tour et je souhaite également vous
dire pourquoi je pense que cette
proposition de rapport supplémentaire
sur une réforme qui viendrait modifier
la réforme sur laquelle nous travaillons
ce qui est quand même un paradoxe me
semble inutile le régime de retraite à
points qualifié d'universel a été rejeté
massivement par les Français lors du
précédent quinquennat du président
Macron obligeant le président et
le gouvernement exécutif d'alors à
abandonner le texte le 10 janvier
dernier madame la Première ministre a
tiré un trait définitif sur l'idée d'une
nouvelle réforme des retraites par point
elle en propose une que l'on qualifiera
de paramétrique et donc je ne vois pas
pourquoi nous remettrions en cause cet
état de fait qui constate un certain
équilibre du débat politique sur cette
question au moment où nous nous parlons
donc on va pas se projeter dans un
avenir tout ce qui est plus incertain à
un an dans le monde tel qu'il est un an
c'est à la fois long et très court donc
je pense que il ne faut pas ajouter
de l'incertitude et agiter un nouveau
spectre d'une future mise en oeuvre d'un
système universel de retraite intégrant
qui plus est les paramètres réforme de
la présente loi donc je suis pour le
retrait de cet article problème
on est d'accord
merci
moi je voudrais insister effectivement
sur le côté étrange de cette amendement
qui propose que au bout d'un an un rat
de cet article pardon pardon qui propose
que un rapport soit remis au bout d'un
an sur différentes façons de mettre en
place une nouvelle réforme des retraites
d'abord on l'a déjà dit mais est-ce que
ça veut dire donc une nouvelle réforme
des retraites se prépare et laquelle
ensuite un an non ça veut dire quoi euh
non quand on connaît la complexité du
sujet ça veut dire quoi ensuite
effectivement qu'en est-il
du des partenaires sociaux qu'en est-il
de de tout ce qui existe de cette
démocratie sociale qui a été mise en
place en France depuis des années à
laquelle je crois beaucoup d'entre nous
tiennent ici pour ne pas dire tous
donc qui va faire ce rapport
sur quelle base avec quels objectifs
je suis vraiment très très étonnée que
ça nous arrivait puis encore
plus étonné qu'on puisse nous proposer
un rapport même si j'ai bien compris que
la Commission n'allait pas donner un
avis favorable mais enfin tout à l'heure
on a été surpris aussi parce que la
Commission n'a pas donné un avis
favorable sur une autre demande de
rapport que nos collègues en face ont
allègrement tous voté donc au final il y
aura un rapport comme quoi les
subterfuges ça peut fonctionner on
aimerait bien de temps en temps que ça
fonctionne pour nous aussi parce qu'on a
plein d'idées intéressantes pour des
rapports
j'espère
merci monsieur le Président cet
amendement témoigne des incohérences et
du mépris du gouvernement à l'égard du
Parlement voilà les sénateurs devraient
suspendre à la séance d'ici quelques
minutes mais en attendant nous allons
rejoindre Audrey Audrey qui se trouve
dans l'hémicycle du Sénat pour revenir
sur l'un des temps forts de cette
matinée avec notamment et bien
l'adoption d'un amendement qui ouvre la
réflexion vers l'injection d'une dose de
capitalisation dans notre système par
répartition oui et avant l'adoption cet
amendement nous avons vécu un grand
moment de débat entre la gauche et la
droite deux systèmes de pensée pour la
France et pour notre système de retraite
qui se sont opposés le thème c'était
faut-il réfléchir ou non à introduire
une dose de capitalisation dans notre
système par répartition la
capitalisation je vous le rappelle c'est
quand on investit ses cotisations dans
les fonds de pension la répartition
c'est notre système actuel c'est quand
les actifs payent pour les retraités
pour les sénateurs de droite un mix est
inévitable si on veut soutenir notre
système c'est notamment la vie du
président du groupe les républicains
Bruno Retailleau
si comme vous comme nous nous sommes
attachés à ce que demain en France il
puisse y avoir des fonds souverains pour
que nos centres de décision ne partent
pas si nous voulons demain en France que
nous ayons de l'argent des Français pour
qu'on puisse investir précisément dans
la transition énergétique la transition
écologique il y aura pas d'autres moyens
c'est la souveraineté financière c'est
la souveraineté industrielle c'est là
qui est l'enjeu et on peut le faire sans
détricoter notre système
à l'opposé de l'hémicycle on estime que
cette idée est injuste qu'elle
profiterait au plus riche et le sénateur
de gauche estime même que ces sénateurs
de droite qui veulent introduire un peu
de capitalisation décrites le système de
solitarité par répartition que nous
connaissons c'est notamment le cas du
sénateur communiste Fabien gay écouter
il y a deux projets de société qui
s'entendent pas de problème
il y a la répartition versus la
capitalisation et vous le dites et vous
le dites très bien pour vous cette
réforme n'est qu'une étape pour
reprendre le chemin de 2019 et au bout
de deux ou trois ans revenir et redire
il faut la capitalisation individuelle
pour tout
ça nous a pris une partie de la matinée
cet après-midi devrait être consacrée à
l'article 2 sur l'index senior merci
merci beaucoup Audrey pour toutes ces
explications et pour en savoir plus
n'hésitez pas à aller sur notre site un
public sénat.fr ou notre rédaction